NOW IN SESSION ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GABRIEL NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A
QUORUM THE SERGEANT AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
THE CLERK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ACOSTA [inaudible]
AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARAMBULA [inaudible]
BAKER [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
BLOOM [inaudible]
BROUGH [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
CALDERON [inaudible]
CARILLO [inaudible]
CERVANTES CHAO AS GEN
[inaudible]
DAVID CHIU [inaudible]
CHOI [inaudible]
KANSEN CHU [inaudible]
COOLEY [inaudible]
COOPER [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
EGGMAN [inaudible]
LARA [inaudible]
PHONE [inaudible]
FRAZIER [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GABRIEL.
SKINNER GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
[inaudible]
GIPSON [inaudible]
GLORIA [inaudible]
GONZALEZ FLETCHER [inaudible]
GRAY [inaudible]
GRAYSON [inaudible]
HARPER [inaudible]
HOLDEN [inaudible]
JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
KALRA.
KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
KILEY [inaudible]
LACKEY [inaudible]
LEVINE [inaudible]
WE KNOW [inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN [inaudible]
MATT [inaudible]
MAYES MCCARTY [inaudible]
MEDINA [inaudible]
MELENDEZ MULLIN [inaudible]
MURATSUCHI [inaudible]
THIS AREA [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
O'DONNELL [inaudible]
QUIRK [inaudible]
QUIRK SILVA [inaudible]
REYES RE BOSS RODRIGUEZ
[inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SALAS SANTIAGO STEINORTH
[inaudible]
SO [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
VOEPEL [inaudible]
WALDRON [inaudible]
WEBER.
WORD MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS
QUORUM IS PRESENT.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND
IN THE GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND
FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S A VOCATION WILL BE
OFFERED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JUSTIN GABRIEL.
EVERY SATURDAY JEWISH
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA.
AND ACROSS THE GLOBE.
GATHER TO READ A PORTION OF THE
TORAH.
A CHAPTER OF OUR PEOPLE STORY.
THIS WEEK WE READ FROM PAR SHOT
SHOW OF TEAM IN THE BOOK OF
DEUTERONOMY.
WE'RE GOT PRESENTS THE PEOPLE OF
ISRAEL WITH A SYSTEM OF LAW AND
JUSTICE.
GOD INSTRUCTS THE PEOPLE TO
APPOINT LEADERS FROM EACH TRIBE.
WHO WILL HELP GUIDE THEM THROUGH
THEIR MOST CHALLENGING DECISIONS?
AS MOSES IS RECOUNTING GOD'S
INSTRUCTIONS. ONE PARTICULAR
VERSE STANDS OUT.
SADEQ SAID ACT HERE DON'T HE
SAYS.
JUSTICE JUSTICE YOU SHALL PURSUE.
NOTABLY THE LEADERS OF THE BIBLE
AREN'T HOUSE TO FIND JUSTICE OR
TO AFFIRM JUSTICE THEY ARE
OBLIGATED TO CHASE AFTER JUSTICE.
SEEK IT AND BUILD TO ORDER
[inaudible]
YOU PURSUANT.
BUT JUSTICE IS MORE THAN A
RELIGIOUS PRINCIPLE IT IS THE
COMMON THREAD THAT CONNECTS OUR
SACRED AMERICAN TAX.
THE PREAMBLE TO THE US
CONSTITUTION REMINDS US THAT THE
FIRST PURPOSE OF OUR UNION IS TO
ESTABLISH JUSTICE.
WE PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO OUR FLAG
BECAUSE IT IS AN EMBLEM OF
LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL.
THE MANDATE OF OUR JUDICIAL
SYSTEM IS CARBON STONE ABOVE THE
ENTRANCE TO THE UNITED STATES
SUPREME COURT.
EQUAL JUSTICE UNDER LAW.
AS PUBLIC SERVANTS THE PURSUIT
OF JUSTICE IS CENTRAL TO OUR
WORK.
IT IS WHY WE ARE IN THIS ROOM.
WE ARE APPROACHING THE SEASON OF
THE JEWISH HIGH HOLY DAYS.
A MONTH IN WHICH WE REFLECT
DEEPLY ON WHO WE ARE AND WHO WE
WANT TO BE.
AS WE CONSIDER THESE QUESTIONS
LET US DRAW INSPIRATION FROM
THOSE IN OUR COMMUNITY WHO TEACH
US EACH DAY HOW TO PURSUE JUST.
JURORS WHO THIS WEEK OPEN THEIR
CLASSROOMS SO THAT OUR CHILDREN
CAN GROW AND THRIVE.
THE COMPASSION OF OUR SOCIAL
WORKERS AND OUR MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS WHO GIVE STRENGTH
TO THE WEARY.
AND HOPE TO THE DOWNTRODDEN.
SO LET US PRAY.
HELLO HE KNEW BELOW HAVE
ATTAINED YOU ARE GOD AND GOD OF
OUR ANCESTORS.
HELP US TO REMEMBER OUR SACRED
OBLIGATION TO PURSUE JUSTICE.
STIR US TO ACTION AND GUIDE US
AS WE WORK TOGETHER. TO BUILD A
STATE AND A WORLD THAT IS TRULY
JOBST.
SADEQ SAID ACT HERE DON'T.
JUSTICE JUSTICE WE SHALL PURSUE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I AM RIGHT YOU TO REMAIN
STANDING FOR TODAY'S FLAG SALUTE
TO BE OFFERED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
PLEASE RECITE THE PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE READY BEGIN
[inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
YEAH STATES [inaudible] ZERO
YEAH IS IT WILL.
BE AN AXIS ARE.
YOU MAY BE SEATED.
THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL.
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER SACRAMENTO
THURSDAY JULY FIFTH TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN THE CINEMATIC TWELVE
MOVIE ON HER LAURA FRIEDMAN THIS
WEEK OR TEN BESIDES SHE FORGOT
CALDERON MOVES.
AND MISS WALDRON SECONDS OF THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE INTRODUCTION AND
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROMTHE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM THE
SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
TODAY'S ABSENCES ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CRISTINA GARCIA FOR ILLNESS
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND.
ASSEMBLY RULE ONE EIGHTEEN AID
TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBERS KALRA
JONES SAWYER LET AND LACKEY TO
HAVE GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON
THE FLOOR TODAY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA AS IN LIKE
HIS GUESTS WILL BE SEATED AT THE
DESK WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBERS TEAM
FRAZIER GIPSON DAVID CHIU EGGMAN
AND THURMAN.
SPEAK ON A GERMAN IN MEMORY
TODAY WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER.
AT THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHORS I
AM GIVING A ONE DAY NOTICE TO
REMOVE THE FOLLOWING BILLS FROM
THE INACTIVE FILE ITEM EIGHT
TWELVE S. B. THREE FORTY NINE
LOTTA.
ITEM A FIFTEEN S. B. TWO EIGHTY
EIGHT HERNANDEZ BY CARILLO.
ITEM EIGHTY FOUR S. B. TWO SIXTY
ONE MINING.
ITEM ELEVEN ESPYS FIVE SEVENTY
NINE GALGIANI.
ITEM A EIGHTEEN S. B. TWO FORTY
FOR A LOT OF AYE DAVID CHIU.
THE CLERK WILL KNOW.
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY
SIX I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT
TO RE REFER HR FIFTY ONE COOPER
FROM THE PUBLIC EMPLOYEE
RETIREMENT AND SOCIAL SECURITY
COMMITTEE TO THE RULES COMMITTEE
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
PLEASE MOVE ITEM NUMBER TWO WHO
TWELFTH SB ELEVEN SIXTY SIX PAN
TO THE INACTIVE FILE THE CLERK
WILL NOTE.
AT THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR
PLEASE RETURN THE FOLLOWING
BILL'S THE SENATE.
ITEM NUMBER FORTY NINE AB FIFTY
NATIVE ORGANS ALSO FLETCHER.
ITEM FIFTY ONE AB SIXTY NINETY
SEVEN INSURANCE COMMITTEE.
I DON'T WANT TO WAIT AB TWENTY
EIGHT SEVENTY EIGHT CHAVEZ
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
AT THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR.
PLEASE RETURN AB TWENTY EIGHT
FIFTY THREE MEDINA.
FROM THE GOVERNOR'S DESK AND
RESCIND THE ACTION WHEREBY THE
BILL WAS REPORTED IN ROLLED INTO
THE GOVERNOR ON AUGUST
FOURTEENTH TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHTEEN WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER.
AT THE REQUEST OF THE OTHERS
PLEASE REMOVE THE FOLLOWING
BILLS FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR
ITEM NUMBER TWO SEVENTY THREE SB
TWELVE EIGHTY THREE BRADFORD.
ITEM NUMBER TWO SIXTY FIVE S. B.
ELEVEN TEN BRADFORD ITEM NUMBER
TWO EIGHTY SEVEN S. B. FIFTEEN
OH FOUR BY THE SENATE PURSE
COMMITTEE.
ITEM TO EIGHTY THREE SB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO HILL AND ITEM TWO
FORTY NINE S. B. EIGHTY NINETEEN
HILL.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
AT THE REQUEST OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK QUIRK.
PLEASE REMOVE THE FOLLOWING
BILLS IN THE CONSENT CALENDAR
ITEM TWO SEVENTY SIX S. B.
THIRTY THIRTY EIGHT HUESO ITEM
TWO SEVENTY EIGHT S. B. THIRTEEN
FIFTY A HUESO AN ITEM.
TO EIGHTY SB THIRTEEN SEVENTY
FOUR HUESO.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER AT THE REQUEST OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN REMOVE
ITEM TO SEE S. THE S. B. THIRTY
TEN THIRTY SIX WELL FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
AND AT THE REQUEST OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OBERNOLTE PLEASE REMOVE
ITEM NUMBER TWO SEVENTY FOUR S.
B. TWELVE NINETY THREE LOT OF
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY SIX
IN WOULD DRAW THE FOLLOWING
BILLS FROM THE BUDGET COMMITTEE
AND ORDERED THEM TO THE THIRD
RING FILE.
AS BILLS ARE SB EIGHT FORTY SIX
SB EIGHT SIXTY ONE S. B. A SIXTY
TWO S. B. EIGHT SIXTY SEVEN S.
B. EIGHT SIXTY NINE S. B..
EIGHT SEVENTY FOUR SB EIGHT
SEVENTY FIVE S. B. EIGHT SEVENTY
SIX S. B..
EIGHT SEVENTY SEVEN S. B. EIGHT
SEVENTY EIGHT S. B. A SEVENTY
NINE MISS WALDRON FOR WHAT
REASON DO RISE WE OPPOSE THE
MOTION THEN ASK FOR ALL CALL.
MEMBERS THIS TAKES FORTY ONE
VOTES.
MR CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
MISTER CALDERON MOVES.
I MISS WALDRON OBJECTS
MEMBERS.
MISTER CALDERON MOVES MS RUBIO
SECONDS [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
THIS REQUIRES FORTY ONE VOTES
MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN
I. MS WALDRON IS ASKING FOR AND
NO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MR CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
AND HOW THE VOTES EYES
[inaudible]
FORTY FIVE KNOWS.
NINETEEN ASSEMBLY RULE.
NINETY SIX A IS SUSPENDED WITH
THE PREVIOUSLY STATED BILLS
.
THE ROLE. SEVEN TWO I AM RE
REFER IN THE FOLLOWING FIELDS TO
COME.
ITEM NUMBER FORTY SEVEN A. B.
TEN SIX TO LEVINE AT TO THE
HIGHER EDUCATION COMMITTEE.
ITEM FIFTY AB SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN
BLOOM TO THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
ITEM SIXTY SEVEN AB TWENTY SIX
TWENTY TING TO THE PRIVACY OF
CONSUMER PROTECTION COMMITTEE.
ITEM EIGHTY ONE A. B. EIGHTY
SEVEN TING TO THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE ITEM EIGHTY FOUR A. B.
FIVE FIVE EIGHT QUIRK SILVA TO
THE TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE.
ITEM EIGHTY SIX AB TWELVE
SEVENTEEN SANTIAGO TO THE
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE.
ITEM EIGHTY SEVEN A. B. THIRTEEN
SEVENTY THREE DAILY TO THE
INSURANCE COMMITTEE ITEM EIGHTY
NINE A. B. FIFTEEN SIXTY FIVE
BERMAN TO THE LABOR AND
EMPLOYMENT COMMITTEE.
ITEM ONE HUNDRED AB TWENTY FOUR
SIXTY NINE BERMAN TO THE
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION.
MEMBERS PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULE SEVENTY SEVEN POINT TWO I
AM RE REFERRING THE FOLLOWING
BILLS TO COMMITTEE
.
SOME MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN YOU
RECOGNIZE.
I THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER YOU
KNOW WE DO A LOT OF IMPORTANT
THINGS IN THIS CHAMBER --
BUT NONE MAY BE MORE IMPORTANT
LEGISLATIVE SOFTBALL
[inaudible]
AND SO --
LAST NIGHT WE WE GOT TOGETHER TO
HAVE A GAME --
WE RAISED FIFTY FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR THE MUSTARD SCHOOL --
WHICH IS A REAL CREDIT TO
EVERYBODY WHO I WHO PITCHED IN
ON THAT.
AND I THINK AT A TIME WHERE WE
SEE AT THE NATIONAL LEVEL WHERE --
INCREASINGLY WHERE PEOPLE CAN'T
EVEN GET TOGETHER AND AND TALK
ABOUT POLITICS OR GET TOGETHER --
AND IF FOR CAMARADERIE WERE
REALLY A GOOD EXAMPLE OF DOING
IT THE RIGHT WAY --
WE GOT TOGETHER LAST NIGHT IN A
VERY COMPETITIVE --
ATMOSPHERE AND ALL OF US
TOGETHER I HAD A GREAT EVENING --
AND THEN AFTERWARDS WASN'T AS
GREAT AS IT COULD HAVE BEEN FOR
OUR SIDE MAYBE BUT THAT.
BUT I WE HAD A REALLY NICE
EVENING TOGETHER IN COMPETITION
BUT ALSO ENCOURAGING ONE ANOTHER
AND THEN AFTERWARDS I TO GET
TOGETHER.
AND VISIT AND CELEBRATE --
I REALLY GREAT EVENING I WON
RECOGNIZE A COUPLE PEOPLE THAT
I'M GONNA ASK AND MR MCCARTY
COME OVER HERE AS WELL --
AND HE'S GONNA RECOGNIZE A FEW
MORE NOT GERMAN THOUGH CURTIS
ROWING ITIS IN JOE'S AND SEE I
REALLY HELPED US.
I OUT I WANT TO I RECOGNIZE THE
MVP.
I I SPENT MOST OF MY EVENING
CHASE RUNNING TO THE FANS
CHASING AFTER THE BALL AS HE HIT --
SO BUT I WON A WRECK NAY SKIN
CALLED AROUND FOR HAVING A
FANTASTIC GAME.
AND THEN ALSO BY YOUR MANAGER.
CRADDICK MANAGER KEVIN CARTY
PUTTING TOGETHER THE PRACTICE.
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO GET THERE IS
A FULL TIME JOB.
I IT.
IT HURTS A TINY BIT TO HAND THIS
OVER I'VE ENJOYED HAVING THIS
FOR THE LAST YEAR WE LOOK
FORWARD TO HOPE TO GETTING IT
BACK NEXT YEAR SO TAKE GOOD CARE
OF IT -- BUT
I WANT TO COMMEND THE PEOPLE IN
THIS ROOM FOR FORGET TOGETHER DO
SOMETHING THAT'S SO ENJOYABLE
FOR OUR WHOLE CAPITAL COMMUNITY.
AYE AND WITHOUT AND MR MCCARTY
IT LIKE THAT PRESENT YOU THAT
GAME WINNING TROPHY.
ALRIGHT
.
IS THAT WE MR MCCARTY ARE
RECOGNIZED FROM.
MR CHANCE THAT'S FAKE YOU OUT
MADAM SPEAKER AGAIN JUST WANTED
TO RECOGNIZE EVERYBODY FOR
PARTICIPATING THE SIXTEENTH
ANNUAL.
LEGISLATIVE ALL STAR GAME --
LOTS OF BIPARTISAN FIND.
FIELD FORTY FIVE RUNS SCORED BUT
MOST IMPORTANTLY A GOOD TEAM
EFFORT FROM THE STATE CAPITOL
COMMUNITY HELPING.
MY DISTRICT HERE IN SACRAMENTO
NOTE THAT A LOCAL NONPROFIT A
FIFTY FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS
RATES FOR THE MUSTARD SEED
SCHOOL FOR HOMELESS CHILDREN.
HAD SOME OF THE FAMILY MEMBERS
COME OUT THERE LAST NIGHT THAT
WAS GREAT.
THERE WERE NO INJURIES SEPARATE
YOUR EGOS RIGHT [inaudible]
YES AND CERTAINLY WE'RE WE'RE
PROUD OF THE DEMOCRAT EFFORT I
DID WONDER RECOGNIZE.
I PEOPLE HELP OF THIS ON
TOGETHER ARE SPARSE DOWN FROM
THE CAPITAL HELP MAKE THIS EVENT
POSSIBLE FOR MY OFFICE CARLA
DOES AND SO LIMIT LANSDOWNE AND
TISHREI WINTER.
THANK YOU FOR ALL OF YOUR WORK.
OUR GAME NIGHT DUGOUT MANAGER
BECAUSE HE WAS INJURED WITH THE
COME BACK NEXT YEAR FREDDIE
RODRIGUEZ THANK YOU FREDDIE.
AND BRIAN DO CAL DOWN IN IN THE
DUGOUT AS WELL AS AS A STAFFER
THE LEGISLATURE AND OH YEAH THE
MIGHTY DEMOCRATS DID WIN THE
GAME --
TWENTY FIVE TO TO TWENTY AYE
DESPITE A SPIRITED NINETEEN IN
RALLY BY THE REPUBLICANS WE HELD
ON AND PRETTY DICEY THERE IN THE
NINTH INNING.
AND PROUD THAT WE HAD TWENTY
THREE DEMOCRAT MEMBERS
CONTRIBUTE IN PLAYING THE GAME
SO THAT ALCOHOL ARE DEMOCRATS
STEPPED UP AND HELP MAKE SURE.
IT WAS THAT A TEAM TEAM VICTORY
LOT OF GREAT PLAYERS LAST NIGHT
NOT A GREAT PLACE BUT OUR MVP
GOES TO OUR MAJORITY LEADER AND
SORT STOP IN CALL.
HE WAS ASKED DADDY IN THE FEEL
OF THEIR SORTS DIE BUT THE BAD
HE DID GO.
FOR FOR SIX WITH TWO HOME RUNS.
FOR FOR SIX FOR FOR SIXTY ONE
RUNS A DOUBLE AND A TRIPLE HE
COULD NOT GOT THE RIGHT TO GET A
SINGLE GOT A CYCLE WHO WAS THE
THINKING.
ON THAT EIGHT RBIS AND FIVE RUNS
SCORED SO PHENOMENAL GAME --
IAN CALDERON THANKS AGAIN
EVERYBODY FOR MAKING THIS A
GREAT EVENT FOR OUR CAPITAL
COMMUNITY THAT'S NOT THE GAME
WHAT'S THE FUN IN THE BIPARTISAN
EFFORT OUT THERE SO.
I ANOTHER --
GREAT NIGHT AND WE'LL BE BACK
AGAIN NEXT YEAR.
MEMBERS WE HAVE GUESTS WITH US
TODAY IN THE ASSEMBLY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER JONES SAWYER
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED YOUR GUESTS
INTRODUCTIONS.
THANK YOU.
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
BOB FIRST OF ALL I WOULD LIKE.
ALL THE MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY.
O. WHO ARE ALUMNI OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA TO PLEASE STAND
THERE'S ELEVEN OF US I BELIEVE
THEY'RE IN THIS CHAMBER.
AS THE UNOFFICIAL CHAIR.
PUBLIC TROJAN LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS.
IT IS MY PLEASURE TO WELCOME TO
THE ASSEMBLY CHAMBER.
THE U. S. SEEM WOMEN'S FOUR BY
FOUR HUNDRED METER RELAY TEAM.
WHO POSTED LIKE DRAMATIC
COMEBACK?
COME FROM BEHIND VICTORY IN THE
LAST.
NC A A TRACK AND FIELD.
TO THEIR VICTORY ALLOWED U. S.%
C. TO CLINCH ITS SECOND TEAM
TITLE IN PROGRAM HISTORY.
ITS FIRST SINCE [inaudible]
TWO THOUSAND ONE MEMBERS.
THESE LADIES KNEW THEY NEEDED TO
WIN THE FINAL EVENT T. EDGE
GEORGIA [inaudible]
AND STANFORD [inaudible]
AND STANFORD. FOR THE TEAM TYPE.
HOWEVER THAT TITLES SEEM LOST
WHEN IT WAS UP BOBBLED OF THE
BATON I WOULD POINT OUT WHO
BOBBLED THE BATON.
AND THEY BALK ON THE FINAL
EXCHANGE.
IT LOOKED LIKE PURDUE.
AND ORGAN WOULD WIN THE RACE.
BUT THEN ANCHOR.
KINDLE ELLIS SEEMED TO FIND
ANOTHER YEAR IN THE FINAL EIGHTY
METERS.
AND BLOOM PASSED THE ORGAN
RUNNER AND NIPPED AT PURDUE
ATHLETE BY POINT ZERO SECONDS.
AT THE WIRE TO WIN THE EVENT
TAKE PLACE THE TEAM TITLE.
THE TROJANS WON WITH FIFTY THREE
POINTS. TO GEORGE FIFTY TWO
POINT.
AND STANFORD AND STANFORD. FIFTY
ONE POINTS THE CLOSEST TOP.
THREE TEAMS FINALS ARE EVER AT
THE NCAA TRACK AND FIELD
CHAMPION SHIPS.
THERE NOW NATIONAL CHAMPIONS
HERE TODAY IS CAN DO WELL US WHO
IS A SEVEN TIME PACKED WORLD
CHAMPION.
AT THIRTEEN TIME ALL AMERICAN IN
THE SPRINTS FOR TROJANS.
DEANNA HILL IS A SIXTEEN TIME
ALL AMERICAN IN THE SPRINTS AND
RELAY FOR U. S. C. THE MOST OF
ALL.
AMERICA DESIGNATIONS EVER BY A
TROJAN WOMAN TRACK AND FIELD
ATHLETE.
AND A COCKROACH RUN FOR U. S. C.
IN OUR FIRST TWO YEARS AT USC.
KYRA CONSTANTINUS RUN FOR U. S.
C. IN HER FIRST TWO SEASONS
THERE.
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING ON THE FLOOR THESE
FOUR PHENOMENAL WOMEN.
AND I MIGHT AND THEY ARE ALSO D.
U. S. TRACK AND FIELD AND CROSS
COUNTRY.
OUTDOOR SCHOLAR.
TEAM OF THE YEAR.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE U. S.
C. ATHLETIC DEPARTMENT FIGHT ON
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GUESTS
INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
I HAVE WITH ME --
WILL SUPPORT PART OF MY LIFE WAY --
MY SON AND MY DAUGHTER --
A DAUGHTER JENNY AND MY SON
JUSTIN PLEASE WELCOME THEM HERE
THANK YOU
.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GUESTS
INTRODUCTIONS.
MEMBERS I THINK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS YOU MIGHT RECALL
JUST DONE EARLIER.
I WOULD ASK THE GAS IN THE REAR
OF THE CHAMBER TO PLEASE MOVE
OUT INTO THE EMPTY ROOM.
STILL WANT TO GREET THEM AND
PLEASE GIVE YOUR TENT TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEVINE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER JUST A
COUPLE DAYS AGO OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM YUBA CITY INTRODUCED A
RESOLUTION ABOUT A RARE DISEASE
AND TODAY VISITING FROM MY
DISTRICT IS A DELEGATION.
FROM ALL FOR JANET'S A NEVADA
BASED PARK BY A PHARMACEUTICAL
COMPANY THAT SPECIALIZES IN
PHARMACEUTICAL RESEARCH FOR RARE
GENETIC DISEASES CULTURE CHECKS
CURRENTLY EMPLOYS FIVE HUNDRED
IMP BUT OVER. FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY
EMPLOYEES HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
THEIR RESEARCH IS INSTRUMENTAL
IN PROVIDING HOPE AND RELIEF TO
THOSE AFFLICTED BY ULTRA.
RARE DISEASES PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING CAMILLE PROTRUSION THE
CHIEF MEDICAL OFFICER DENNIS
WONG THE CHIEF TECHNICAL
OPERATIONS OFFICER.
CARA PAR SHOWER THE EVP AND
GENERAL COUNSEL AND HIVE SUPPORT
PER THIS SENIOR VP AND THE REST
OF THE DELEGATION FROM ULTRA
CHEN EXIT IS VISITING HERE TODAY
THANK YOU GUYS SO MUCH FOR BEING
HERE THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR
RESEARCH.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA YOUR
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GUESTS
INTRODUCTIONS.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER UP WITH
ME AT MY DESK IS MY NEPHEW
JUSTIN KALRA.
WHO'S ABOUT TO GO INTO SIXTH
GRADE IS ELEVEN YEARS OLD.
BALLPARK HERE WITH HIS MOM WAS
IN THE BACK --
SUMMON KILOMETERS A REALTOR.
AND SO PLEASE COME BY AND SAY HI
TO JUDGE IF YOU DO NOT GET A
CHANCE TO HARLEM --
YESTERDAY HE WAS OF THE GAME HAD
AN OPPORTUNITY TO WATCH
[inaudible]
RATS TORY IT'S RIGHT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GUESTS
INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
IT GIVES ME GREAT PLEASURE TO
WELCOME PATTY PARLIAMENT DESI.
TO THE STATE ASSEMBLY SITTING
APPEARED IN THE IN THE GALLERY.
AS PART OF HER DREAM OF HELPING
OTHERS.
SHE AUTHORED THE INSPIRATIONAL
MEMOIR.
THE OTHER FOUR LETTER WORD PATTY
STORY.
IN HOPES OF HELPING OTHERS TO
CONQUER THE CHALLENGES IN THEIR
LIFE.
FROM THE AGE OF TWO PATIO
STRUGGLED WITH EPILEPSY.
IN NOW IS GIVING BACK TO OTHERS
TO UNDERSTAND.
EXCEPT THE STRUGGLE AND TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH A POSITIVE ATTITUDE.
FOR ITS SUCCESSFUL LIFE.
PADDY HAS SPENT HER LIFE BATTLE
LEAN THE PAINFUL SEIZURES OF
APPS EPILEPSY.
AND HAD TO UNDERGO THREE BRAIN
SURGERIES AS HER CONDITION
WORSENED.
WHEN SHE AWOKE REMOTE MEMORY WAS
GONE?
COULD NOT EVEN WRITE HER NAME
SHE SAID.
I HAD TO RE TEACH MYSELF
EVERYTHING.
NOW I HAVE A LIFE AGAIN COMPARED
TO WHAT IT USED TO BE.
SHE HAS BEEN A LIFELONG
VOLUNTEER FOR OTHERS BUT THIS
VENTURE IS ESPECIALLY CLOSE TO
HER HEART.
MEMBERS PLEASE HELP ME IN
WELCOMING PADDY.
THE STATE ASSEMBLY.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
SECOND READING MISTER CLERK
PLEASE READ.
ASSUMING CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TO SIXTY WITH AMENDMENTS I
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE TENTH
OF A MINUTE SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE FORTY WITH A
MINUTE SENATE BILL.
298-327-72820 491-998-2111 AWAIT
ELEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN TOLD ME ONCE
WILL BE 712-881-33313
713-751-39314 23-14
429-799-21030 FOUR TEN FORTY SIX
ELEVEN ON 911-641-19112 FORTY
EIGHT TWELVE BEFORE.
1-261-126-2130 THIRTEEN EIGHTY
SIX FOURTEEN FIFTY ONE FOURTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN FOURTEEN NINETY ONE
FOURTEEN NINETY FOUR FOURTEEN
NINETY FIVE AND SENATE BILL
ELEVEN FIFTY TWO WITH AMENDMENTS.
ALL THOSE HAVE BEEN DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED.
ITEMS.
FORTY ONE THROUGH ONE THIRTY
NINE PASS TEMPORARILY.
WE ARE MOVING TO SENATE BILL
THIRD READING.
ITEMS ONE THIRTY EIGHT THREE ONE
FORTY THREE PASS TEMPORARILY
MOVING TO ITEM [inaudible]
ONE FORTY FOUR S. B.. NINE FORTY
SIX LARA BY ORDER GARCIA MISTER
CLERK PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL NINE FORTY SIX BY
SENATOR LLOREN OTHERS
INOCULATING SIDEWALK VENDORS. TO
GARCIA WITH AMENDMENTS
.
PASS TEMPORARILY ON THAT ITEM
OKAY ONE FORTY FIVE THREE ONE
MOVING TO ITEM ONE FORTY EIGHT
BE A TWELVE A QUICKLY.
THREE SENATE BILL EIGHT TWENTY
ONE WITH AMENDMENTS BY SOME
WOMEN REALLY BONE.
ASSEMBLYMAN THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER S. B. EIGHT TWENTY ONE
WOULD AUTHORIZE COUNTIES TO
AUTOMATICALLY ENROLL RESIDENTS
INTO COUNTY OPERATED EMERGENCY
NOTIFICATION SYSTEMS WHILE ALSO
ALLOWING IN RULED RESIDENTS TO
OPT OUT.
OF RECEIVING EMERGENCY ALERTS
FROM THE SYSTEMS.
THE FLORA MEMONS WHAT
ADDITIONALLY AUTHORIZED COUNTY
SOCIAL SERVICE AGENCIES TO
CONTACT RESIDENTS WITH ACCESS OR
FUNCTIONAL NEEDS IN ORDER TO
PROVIDE THEM WITH ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION OR OTHER ASSISTANCE
DURING EMERGENCIES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON THE AMENDMENT.
THANK YOU WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SIGNIFY BY SAYING AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED.
THANK YOU THE AYE AYE THE
AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED THE ITEM
IS OUT TO PRETTY BACK ON FILE.
LIVING TO ITEM ONE FORTY NINE S.
B. TWELVE THIRTY FIVE GLAZER BY
LIMON MISTER QUICKLY ST.
SENATE BILL TWELVE THIRTY FIVE
AMENDMENTS BY SOME MEMBER BILLY
BONES.
THANK YOU SOME EVER LAMONT THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
SP TWELVE THIRTY FIVE WOULD FOR
THE FIRST TIME REQUIRE TRUTHIN
LENDING DISCLOSURES ON SMALL
BUSINESS LOANS LENDERS WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO DISCLOSE THE AMOUNT
OF FINANCING THE TOTAL COST OF
THE FINANCING.
THE TERM THE AMOUNT AND
FREQUENCY OF PAYMENTS PREPAYMENT
POLICIES AND THE ANNUALIZED RATE.
THESE AMENDMENTS WOULD REQUIRE
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF BUSINESS
OVERSIGHT TO PROVIDE GUIDANCE TO
LENDERS ON HOW TO DISCLOSE EACH
OF THOSE ITEMS.
THE BILL WOULD NOT REQUIRE ANY
LENDER NOT NOW LICENSE TO
REGISTER WITH THE D. V. O. THE
AMENDMENTS CLARIFY THAT THE
DEPARTMENT COULD ENFORCE THESE
PROVISIONS THROUGH THOSE LENDERS
WHO ARE ALREADY LICENSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON THE AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SIGNIFY BY SAYING AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED.
THE AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED THE
ITEM IS BACK ON FILE AND HOW TO
PRINT
.
MOVING BACK TO ITEM ONE FORTY
FOUR MISTER CLERK PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL NINE FORTY SIX WITH
AMENDMENTS BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
AMERICA ARSIA.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE TO PRESENT AS
SPEED NINE FORTY SIX SENATOR
LOTT FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS.
THE AMENDMENTS BEFORE THIS BODY
CLARIFY THAT LOCAL AUTHORITIES
MAY PROHIBIT STATIONARY SIDEWALK
VENDORS IN AREAS THAT ARE
EXCLUSIVELY RESIDENTIAL.
ALLOW LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
REGULATE TIME PLACE AND MANNER
OF SIDEWALK BENDING.
RESTRICT SIDEWALK VENDORS WITH
AN IMMEDIATE VICINITY OF ANY
AREA DESIGNATED FOR TEMPORARY
SPECIAL PERMIT ISSUED BY LOCAL
AUTHORITY.
PROVIDES AN ADMINISTRATIVE FINE
SCHEDULE FOR BENDING WITHOUT A
PERMIT.
PASSED FOR THESE AMENDMENTS TO
BE ADOPTED AND FOR THE BILL TO
BE PUT BACK ON FILE.
THANK YOU WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THIS ITEM
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SIGNIFY BY
SAYING AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED.
THE AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTEDHIM
THAT THE ITEM IS OUT OF PRINT
AND BACK ON FILE.
MOVING TO ITEM ONE FIFTY SJR
TWENTY TWO HUESO BY GONZALEZ
FLETCHER MR QUICKLY THREE SENATE
JOINT RESOLUTION TWENTY TWO OF
THE MINUTES BY SOME REMEMBER
GONZALEZ FLETCHER. SEVEN NEVER
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
THANK YOU AYE RIGHT FOR PURPOSES
OF AMENDMENTS FOR SJ ARE TRYING
TO WHICH URGES THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
I HAD TO TAKE IMMEDIATE ACTION
TO ADEQUATELY ADDRESS CROSS
BORDER POLLUTION THE TIJUANA
RIVER VALLEY RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR MY VOTE.
THANK YOU WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SIGNIFY BY SAYING AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED.
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
ADOPTED THE ITEM IS OUT OF PRINT
AND BACK ON FILE.
ITEMS ONE FIFTY ONE THROUGH ONE
FIFTY SIX PASS TEMPORARILY
MOVING TO ITEM OF ONE FIFTY
SEVEN S. B. FOURTEEN TWENTY
SEVEN HELL BORROWING MISTER
QUICKLY STREET.
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN TWENTY
SEVEN WITH AMENDMENTS BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER IRWIN SEVEN EVER
IRWIN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED MADAM
SPEAKER THE AMENDMENTS TO SP
FOURTEEN TWENTY SEVEN CORRECTIVE
MINOR.
SPELLING ERROR I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT THE BILL GO OUT
PRETTY PLACE BACK.
THANK YOU WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THIS ITEM
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SIGNIFY BY
SAYING AYE [inaudible]
ALL OPPOSED.
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
ADOPTED THE BILL IS OUT OF PRINT
AND BACK ON FILE.
ITEMS ONE OF FIFTY EIGHT THROUGH
ONE SIXTY FIVE PASS TEMPORARILY.
MOVING TO ITEM ONE SIXTY SIX S.
B. NINE TO NINE MISTER QUICKLY
STREET SO THE BILL NINE TWENTY
NINE WITH THE MINUTES BY SOME
REMEMBER BLOOM.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANKS MAN OF SPEAKER
S. B. NINE TWENTY NINE WILL
REQUIRE EVERY INDEPENDENT
SPECIAL DISTRICT TO CREATE AND
CONSISTENTLY MAINTAIN.
A WEBSITE WITH SPECIFIC AND
DETAILED INFORMATION AND IT'LL
REQUIRE THIS BEGUN BY JANUARY
ONE TWENTY TWENTY AMENDMENTS
BEING TAKEN ON THE FLOOR TODAY
ARE CLARIFYING IN NATURE TO
ADDRESS THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS CONCERNS.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR IVA.
THANK YOU WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
PLEASE SAY AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED.
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
ADOPTED THE BILL IS OUT OF PRINT
AND BACK ON FILE.
ITEMS ONE SIXTY SEVEN THROUGH
ONE EIGHTY ONE PASS TEMPORARILY.
MOVING TO ITEM ONE EIGHTY TWO S.
B. NINE FIFTY FOUR MISTER CLERK
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL NINE FIFTY FOUR WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOME REMEMBER
CUNNINGHAM.
THANK YOU WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
WILL TAKE OF VOICE OH SORRY
MISTER CUNNINGHAM YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER S. B.
NINE FIFTY FOUR OH REQUIRED
ATTORNEY REPRESENTING A CLIENT
IN A MEDIATION TO PROVIDE THE
CLIENT WITH THE DISCLOSURE.
ON THE CONFIDENCE
CONFIDENTIALITY RESTRICTIONS IN
MEDIATION AND OBTAIN DECIDED
KNOWLEDGE MINT THESE AMENDMENTS
CLARIFY THE TIMING. FOR WHEN
THIS DISCLOSURE PROVIDE TO THE
CLIENT AND MAKE OTHER TECHNICAL
CHANGES I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THIS
ITEM ALL THOSE IN FAVOR PLEASE
SIGNIFY BY SAYING AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED.
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
ADOPTED THE BILL IS OUT OF PRINT
AND BACK ON FILE.
ITEMS.
ONE EIGHTY THREE THROUGH TO GO
TO PASS TEMPORARILY MOVING TO
ITEM TO A THREE SB.
SEVEN FIFTEEN NINE THE CLERK
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SOME PRETTY NON WITH
AMENDMENTS ARE SOME REMEMBER
MULLIN.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER SB SEVEN
FIFTY NINE CREATES A PROCESS FOR
LOCAL ELECTIONS OFFICIALS TO
NOTIFY VOTERS WITH THEIR VOTE BY
MAIL BALLOTS SIGNATURE MIS
MATCHES THE ONE ON FILE.
IT ALSO GUARANTEES THESE VOTERS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO CORRECT THE
MISMATCH.
SO THAT THEIR VOTES CAN BE
COUNTED OVER TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND RESIDENTS BALLOTS WERE
THROWN OUT IN CALIFORNIA'S
NOVEMBER TWENTY SIXTEEN GENERAL
GENERAL ELECTION BECAUSE OF A
MISMATCHING SIGNATURE.
THIS BILL HAS BEEN PAINSTAKINGLY
CRAFTED THROUGH CONSENSUS
BUILDING PROCESS WITH THE ACLU
COUNTY REGISTRARS ANDSECRETARY
OF STATE.
AMENDMENTS BEING TAKEN ON THE
FLOOR TODAY SIMPLY ADDED URGENCY
BECAUSE OF THE BILL TO ENSURE
THAT A CLEAR PROCESS FOR
MISMATCHING SIGNATURES IS IN
PLACE IN TIME. FOR THE NOVEMBER
TWENTY EIGHTEEN ELECTION.
I ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE ON THE
MINUTES.
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE YOUR
ATTENTION TO MISS WALDRON IS
WALDRON FOR A REASON DO YOU RISE
UP WE OPPOSE THE AMENDMENTS AND
ASK FOR ROLL CALL.
THANK YOU WILL I THINK A ROLL
CALL VOTE ON THE AMENDMENT THE
CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE ON THE A ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MR CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES I FORTY
SIX KNOWS TWENTY ONE THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED THE BILL
IS OUT OF PRINT AND BACK ON FILE.
ITEMS TO A FOURTH OR TWO OH SIX
PASS TEMPORARILY.
ITEM TO OF SEVEN S. B. NINE
SIXTY FIVE MISTER CLERK PLEASE
READ.
SENATE BILL NINE SIXTY FIVE WITH
AMENDMENTS BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
EDUARDO GARCIA.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA.
MY SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES S. B.
NINE SIX FIVE ALLOWS FAMILY
CATTLE RANCHERS THE RIGHT TO
VOTE AND DECIDE WHETHER OR NOT.
THEY WANT TO ESTABLISH THE
CALIFORNIA COUNTY COUNCIL.
MOMENTS BEING TAKEN OUT FOR
TODAY CLARIFY THAT THE ANNUAL
BUDGET FOR THE COUNCIL SHALL BE
POSTED UNDER PUBLIC WEBSITE
[inaudible]
SPECULATES RELIABLE.
THANK YOU WOULD NOT WITHOUT
OBJECTION WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE
ON THE AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR PLEASE SIGNIFY BY SAYING
AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED.
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ADOPTED
THE BILL IS OUT OF PRINT AND
BACK ON FILE.
ITEMS TO EIGHT THROUGH TWO
TWENTY FIVE PASS TEMPORARILY
MOVING TO ITEM TO SIX SPU ONE
THIRTY FOUR MISTER QUICKLY.
THREE SENATE BILL ONE THIRTY
FOUR WITH THE MINUTES BY SOME
REMEMBER SALAS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SALAS YOUR
RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS DELETE
PROVISIONS OF TERM BILL TO DEAL
WITH REGIONAL CENTERS
RESPECTFULLY ASPIRIN AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
MISS WALDRON.
I OPPOSE THIS MOTION AND ASK FOR
ROLL CALL.
THANK YOU.
WE WILL TO TAKE A ROLL CALL VOTE
ON THE AMENDMENTS MISTER QUICK
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
MR CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES.
AYES FORTY SIX NO NINETEEN THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED
THE BILL IS OUT OF PRINT AND
BACK ON FILE.
I HAVE TO TWENTY SEVEN SP
SEVENTY SIX MISTER QUICKLY ST.
SENATE BILL SEVENTY SIX WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOME REVERB XIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHEN.
THANK YOU MINISTER A RICE
RESENTED THAT IS FOR SP SEVENTY
SIX WHICH IS EIGHT YEARS THE
MEASURE.
THAT GIVES AN ADDITIONAL NINETY
DAYS ON ALL LICENSE RENEWAL SUCH
EXPIRE IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN ADDITIONALLY
THIS BILL EXTEND THE DEADLINE BY
NINETY DAYS FOR NEW CALIFORNIANS
TO REGISTER THEIR OUT OF STATE
CARS.
THESE AMENDMENTS ARE CRITICAL TO
ADDRESS A SIGNATURE WAIT TIMES
AT THE DMV.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIGHT VOTE.
THANK YOU WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THIS ITEM
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR PLEASE SAY
AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED PLEASE SAY NAY.
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
ADOPTED THE BILL IS OUT OF PRINT
AND BACK ON FILE.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE BACK FOR A
VERY SPECIAL GUEST INTRODUCTION
FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY YOUR
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I AM
PLEASED TO RECOGNIZE IN THE
GALLERY ANGELA ANDERSON SHE'S
BEEN SELECTED TO TWENTY EIGHTEEN
PROJECT LEAD.
NATIONAL TEACHER OF THE YEAR SHE
WORKS AT ANTELOPE HIGH SCHOOL.
I WAS IN MY DISTRICT BUT SHE'S A
PRODUCT AND LIVES IN MISTER
KYLIE'S DISTRICT IN THE ROSE
BOWL AREA AND I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WORK SERVING OUR OUR
STUDENTS IN OUR YOUTH --
TYPICALLY FOCUSING ON TEACHER
DEVELOPMENT AND SCIENCE AND STEM
EDUCATION THANK YOU ARE WELCOME
AS THEY CAPITAL [inaudible]
THANK YOU WE ARE MOVING BACK. TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE. TO
ITEM TO TWENTY EIGHT SP FOUR
SEVENTY THREE MISTER CLERK
PLEASE READ.
SO THE BILL FOR SEVENTY THREE
WITH AMENDMENTS BY SOME REMEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS TODAY PRESENT AMENDMENTS
TO SP FOUR SEVEN THREE ON BEHALF
OF SENATOR HERTZBERG.
THESE AMENDMENTS ARE MAKE
SEVERAL TECHNICAL CHANGES TO
ENSURE THAT THE SAFE HARBOR
PROGRAM AND THE CALIFORNIA
ENDANGERED SPECIES ACT RELY ON
THE BEST AVAILABLE SCIENCE AND
INCREASED TRANSPARENCY.
AYE ASTRAEA AYE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THIS ITEM
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SIGNIFY BY
SAYING AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED.
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CREE
HEARD IN THE I'D ARE ADOPTED THE
ITEM IS OUT OF PRINT
[inaudible]
FILE
BACK IN FILE ORDER TO ITEM
ONE TWENTY TWO S. B.. THREE
TWENTY EIGHT FOR RECONSIDERATION
MISTER QUICKLY ST.
SENATE BILL THREE TWENTY EIGHT
BY SENATOR PORTANTINO AND OTHERS
ARE NOT RIGHT PEOPLE ATTENDANCE
THANK YOU WITHOUT OBJECTION
RECONSIDERATION IS GRANTED.
WE ARE NOW MOVING WE'RE STAYING
ON ONE TWENTY TWO S. B. THREE
TWENTY EIGHT ON THE AMENDMENTS
MISTER QUICKLY.
THREE SENATE BILL THREE TWENTY
EIGHT WITH AMENDMENTS BY SOME
WE'VE EVER GLORIA.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER --
I'D.
SENATE BILL THREE TWENTY AND
MINUTES WOULD SIMPLY EXEMPT
RULES SCHOOL DISTRICTS FROM THIS
MEASURE IT WOULD MAKE OTHER
TECHNICAL DATE CHANGES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON THESE AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU HAVE A SPEAKER.
THANK YOU WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SIGNIFY BY SAYING AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED.
THE AMENDMENTS ADOPTED THE ITEM
IS OUT OF PRINT AND BACK ON FILE
.
ITEMS TWO TWENTY NINE AND TWO
THIRTY PASS AND RETAIN MOVING TO
ITEM TWO THIRTY ONE AS TWELVE
SEVENTY FOUR MISTER QUICKLY.
THREE SENATE BILL TWELVE SEVENTY
FOUR WITH THE MINUTES BY SOME
REMEMBER RUBIO [inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RUBIO.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS TODAY AND
PRESENTING SP TWELVE SEVENTY
FOUR BY MCGUIRE THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES. TO DISCLOSE
ELIGIBILITY AND ENROLLMENT DATA
FOR THE CAL WORKS AND CAL FRESH
PROGRAMS TO DDS. TO ASSIST IN
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF EMPLOYMENT
FIRST POLICY.
PLEASE NOTE THAT THIS IS A VOTE.
ON THE AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL
WHICH WERE DONE TO ADDRESS
CHAPTER RING OUT ISSUES THIS
BILL HAS BEEN MADE ON HAS BEEN
THE CONSENT CANDIDATE THROUGHOUT
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
THANK YOU AND I'D STRONGLY I ASK
FOR YOUR I THINK YOU WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR SIGNIFY BY SAYING AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED SIGNIFY BY
SAYING NAY.
THE AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED THE
BILL IS OUT OF PRINT AND BACK ON
FILE.
ITEM TO THIRTY FIVE PASS AND
RETAIN.
I AM TO THIRTY SIX ESSIE OUR
THIRTY EIGHT MISTER QUICKLY
SERENE.
SENATE CONCURRENT WITH THIRTY
EIGHT BY CENTER ATKINS OF
ACCOLADE RECORDING LEGISLATIVE
MEETINGS.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THE MORE DEMAND GOOD MORNING
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY 2% SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION.
THIRTY EIGHT ON BEHALF OF PRO
TEM TONI ATKINS.
OF THIS MEASURE PROVIDES RULES
RECORD THE PLACEMENT AND USE OF
EQUIPMENT FOR RECORDER
BROADCASTING.
OPEN AND PUBLIC PLEDGE SHAPE
MEETINGS.
OUR IS A BY PRODUCT OF
BIPARTISAN A BICAMERAL WORK.
THE RULES RATED THE PLACE FROM
THE USE OF ACCORDING.
EQUIPMENT COMMITTEE HEARING
ROOMS AND THE PUBLIC HOURS OF OF
THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR.
WILL ENSURE THAT THIS SORT OF
RECORDED AND TELEVISED YOU KNOW
UNFOLDS WITHOUT DISRUPTING THE
CONDUCT OF MEETINGS.
IT PROTECTS THE RIGHT TO RECORD
A PUBLIC PROCEEDS OF THE
LEGISLATURE.
WHILE SETTING GROUND RULES FOR
MINIMIZING DISRUPTION OF THOSE
PROCEEDS PURSUANT THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION --
THE MEMBERS TAKEN ON JULY THIRD
SPECIFICALLY ADDRESSED CONCERNS
RAISED WITH THE VERSION OF THE
MEASURE AS PASSED REVIEW BY THE
SENATE.
THE MEMBERS CLARIFY THE RECORD
RULES AND GIVE GREATER NOTICE TO
THE PUBLIC ABOUT THE RULES.
COULD THEY WILL BE AVAILABLE IN
THE RULES COULD ROOMS AND ON OUR
WEBSITE --
AND AYE URGENT AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALY.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I JUST
WANT -- TO
SAY IT IT'S BEEN A GREAT
BIPARTISAN BILL TO MOVE THIS
FORWARD AND AYE URGING AYE VOTE
ON THIS BILL.
THINK YOU SEE NO FURTHER REQUEST
TO SPEAK MISTER QUICK PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MR CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTES AYE AYES
SIXTY EIGHT NO.
ZERO THE ITEM PASSES.
THANK YOU WE'LL BE BACK IN A
PILE ORDER TO ITEM TWO THIRTY
FOUR S. B. THIRTEEN SIXTY FIVE
MISTER QUICKLY STREET.
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN SIXTY FIVE
AMENDMENTS BY SOME WOMEN WOULD
WATER SEAL THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GARCIA YOU RECOGNIZE THE
MAN OF SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES I
RISE FOR PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS
TO PRESENT S. B.. THIRTEEN SIXTY
FIVE BY SINGING SENATOR FROM SAN
DIEGO.
CRITICAL BILL NEEDED TEXT BUT
I'D URGENTLY NEEDED RESTORATION
EFFORTS AT THE SALTON SEA TO
SPECIFIC AMENDMENTS RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR I WILL.
THANK YOU WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SIGNIFY BY SAYING AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED.
THE AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED THE
BILL IS OUT OF PRINT AND BACK ON
FILE.
ITEM CHIU THIRTY SEVEN SP TENNIS
SEVENTY SIX HURTS HER BY RIVAS A
QUICKLY ST.
SENATE BILL TEN SEVENTY SIX WITH
AMENDMENTS BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
REBUS THANK YOU IT'S A MEMORY
THIS YEAR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER ON THESE
AMENDMENTS TO S. B. TEN SEVENTY
SIX OUR TECHNICAL AND CLARIFYING
AND ARE RESULT OF CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SIGNIFY BY SAYING AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED.
THE AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED THE
BILL IS OUT OF PRINT AND BACK ON
FILE
.
ITEM TWO FORTY PASS AND RETAIN
I AM SORRY MOVING TO ITEM.
TWO THIRTY SEVEN I'M SORRY ITEM
TO THIRTY NINE SB SEVEN SEVENTY
FOUR MISTER CLERK PLEASE THREE
SENATE BILL SEVEN SEVENTY FOUR
WITH AMENDMENTS BY SOME REMEMBER
FLOOR.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FLOOR YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER THESE
AMENDMENTS REMOVE THE CONTENTS
OF SB SEVEN SEVEN FOUR RELATED
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC
SUBSTANCES SUBSTANCE CONTROL.
IS SO THE STATUS OF THE WILD
LAND AND WHILE IN URBAN
INTERFACE WILDFIRE RESEARCH
PROGRAM AT THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY.
PURSES PROGRAMS TO HELP US
IDENTIFY THE BEST STRATEGIES TO
MINIMISE AND MITIGATE HEALTH AND
SAFETY RISK EXPERIENCE BY.
FIREFIGHTERS IN THE FIELD THE
PROGRAM WILL BE ADMINISTERED BY
QUALIFY CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY IN. TO BE DETERMINED
BY THE USE S. C. BURT BOARD OF
TRUSTEES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
THREE MINUTES BE ADOPTED.
OUT TO PRINT AND BACK ON FILE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SIGNIFY BY SAYING AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED.
I BELIEVE I HEARD THAT THE EYES
HAD OF THE AMENDMENTS ARE
ADOPTED THE BILL IS OUT OF PRINT
AND BACK ON FILE.
MEMBERS PURSUANT TO RULE SEVEN
SEVEN POINT TOO I AM RE
REFERRING THE FOLLOWING BILLS TO
COMMITTEE.
ITEM TO TWENTY SIX SP ONE THIRTY
FOUR HERNANDEZ TO HEAR SERVICES
COMMITTEE ITEM TO TWENTY SEVEN
SP SEVENTY SIX NIELSEN TO THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE.
ITEM TO THIRTY NINE SB SEVEN
SEVENTY FOUR LABOR TO THE HIGHER
EDUCATION COMMITTEE
.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THEY IMMENSELY REMEMBERS THIS
MORNING WE'VE A VERY SPECIAL
GROUP OF GUEST VJ SESSION FOR
THE GALLERY.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING
MEMBERS THE AMERICAN FEDERATION
OF GOVERNMENT FORTIES FROM
DISTRICTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
MEMBERS THE SEXUAL SENSUAL EVER
COUNCIL TO SAY CAPITAL.
PLEASE DON'T EMAIL IT WILL
.
MEMBERS PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULE SEVENTY SEVEN POINT TWO I
AM RE REFER IN THE FOLLOWING
BILLS TO COMMITTEE.
ITEM ONE FORTY NINE SP TWELVE
THIRTY FIVE GLAZER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
ITEM UP TO THIRTY FOUR SP
THIRTEEN SIXTY FIVE HUESO TWO
WATER PARKS AND WILDLIFE
MISTER
CALDERON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTY SIX
TO ALLOW THE HEALTH COMMITTEE TO
SET A. B. SIX FIFTY THREE
CUNNINGHAM ON TUESDAY AUGUST
TWENTY FIRST PENNY REFERRAL FROM
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
[inaudible]
WITHOUT OBJECTION SHALL BE THE
ORDER OF THREE BECAUSE OF THE
OTHER PLEASE REMOVE THE
FOLLOWING BILL FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ITEMS NUMBER TWO FIFTY
SEVEN S. B. NINETY ONE DOLLAR.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH BE THE
ORDER AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR PLEASE REMOVE THE
FOLLOWING BILLS FOR THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ITEM THIRTY SEVEN SB
FOUR EIGHTEEN NINETY ONE BY THE
SENATE BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
AND CON DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
MEMBERS WE AREMOVING BACK ON
THE FILE TO ITEM ONE SEC ONE
TWENTY SIX ACR TWO SIXTY FIVE
MISTER CLERK PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TO SIXTY FIVE BY SOME RIVER
BREMER WROTE SUCH CALIFORNIA
COMPUTER SCIENCE EDUCATION MARK.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THINK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES COMPUTER SCIENCE IS
TRANSFORMING INDUSTRY BOLSTERING
PRODUCTIVITY AND DRIVING JOB
CREATION AND INNOVATION.
ACCESS TO COMPUTER SCIENCE
EDUCATION FOR ALL CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS ESPECIALLY YOUNG WOMEN
AND UNDERREPRESENTED MINORITIES
IS CRITICAL TO ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIA REMAINS COMPETITIVE.
IN THE GLOBAL ECONOMY.
IN SEPTEMBER THE STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION IS ANTICIPATED TO
ADOPT CALIFORNIA'S FIRST OF ALL
EVER MODEL COMPUTER SCIENCE
STANDARDS.
IN ADDITION THE BOARD WILL
REVIEW AND DISCUSS
RECOMMENDATIONS DEVELOP BY THE
COMPUTER SCIENCE STRATEGIC
IMPLEMENTATION ADVISORY PANEL
FOR EQUITABLY SCALING KATE
THROUGH TWELVE COMPUTER SCIENCE
EDUCATION.
ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
ALSO IN SEPTEMBER THE
INSTRUCTIONAL QUALITY COMMISSION
WILL BE PRESENTED WITH A DRAFT
COMPUTER SCIENCE STRATEGIC
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN.
GIVEN THE UPCOMING DEVELOPMENTS
IN COMPUTER SCIENCE EDUCATION.
ACR TWO SIXTY FIVE WOULD
DESIGNATE SEPTEMBER TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN AS CALIFORNIA COMPUTER
SCIENCE EDUCATION MONTH.
AND WOULD HIGHLIGHT THE CRUCIAL
ROLE THAT COMPUTER SCIENCE PLAYS.
AND PROVIDING STUDENTS THE
SKILLS THEY NEED TO THRIVE IN
THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY ECONOMY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON EACH YEAR TO SIXTY FIVE
AND ASK THAT THE FIRST ROLE BE
OPENED FOR COAUTHORS.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER REAVIS
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
Q. MADAM SPEAKER I I WOULD LIKE
TO EXPRESS MY GRATITUDE TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN FOR
PROPOSING THIS RESOLUTION AND TO
LEND MY STRONG SUPPORTER IN
DESIGNATED SEPTEMBER.
AS CALIFORNIA COMPUTER SCIENCE
EDUCATION MONTH.
COMPUTER SCIENCE IS AMONG THE
FASTEST GROWING AND MOST IN
DEMAND OCCUPATIONS AND ARE
INCREASING DIGITAL ECONOMY.
IN ORDER TO REMAIN COMPETITIVE
BOTH NATIONALLY AND
INTERNATIONALLY CALIFORNIA CAN
AND SHOULD DO MORE TO ENSURE
THAT CHILDREN OF ALL BACKGROUNDS
AND ALL COMMUNITIES ARE GIVEN
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SUCCEED IN
THIS FIELD.
THIS DESIGNATION WILL RAISE
AWARENESS OF THE NEED FOR
COMPUTER SCIENCE EDUCATION AND
HELP NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS
DEATH DEDICATED TO INSPIRING
CHILDREN TO PURSUE STEM CAREERS --
ALL OVER CALIFORNIA IRIS.
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SEEING NO FURTHER
REQUEST TO SPEAK MISTER BERMAN.
DO YOU HAVE ANY CLOSING COMMENTS
NO MA'AM THANK YOU THE MEMBER
HAS REQUESTED THAT THE FIRST
RULE BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS
MISTER CLICK PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLE.
ROSE PROPOSED AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION.
THIS ROLES FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
MEMBERS THIS ROLE IS FOR CO
AUTHORS.
ON COMPUTER SCIENCE MONTH.
MR CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES THERE ARE
SIXTY NINE CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION WITHOUT OBJECTION
WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THIS
ITEM ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SIGNIFY
BY SAYING AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED.
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED WE ARE
RETURNING TO MISTER BERMAN FIRST
GUEST INTRODUCTIONS.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER IT IS MY
PLEASURE TO WELCOME FOLKS WHO
ARE HERE TODAY THE HIGHLIGHT
COMPUTER SCIENCE EDUCATION MONTH.
AND BRING AWARENESS TO THE
SIGNIFICANT WORK THAT IS
CURRENTLY UNDER WAY.
I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY
WELCOMING A FORMER MEMBER OF
THIS HOUSE SUSAN BONITA WHO
AUTHORED CRITICAL LEGISLATION TO
DEVELOP RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
COMPUTER SCIENCE STRATEGIC
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN.
AND THE MS BUNNY IS CONTINUING
HER EFFORTS AS A MEMBER OF THE
ADVISORY PANEL.
IN THE GALLERY I WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO WELCOME JERRY M. ALONG IN THE
COMPUTER SCIENCE COORDINATOR FOR
THE SACRAMENTO COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION.
JONATHAN NOBLE THE DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FOR MICROSOFT.
PAMELA COUNCILMEN THE EDUCATION
PROGRAM CONSULTANT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION.
AND TRISH BOY WILLIAMS WHO HAS
SERVED AS A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION SINCE TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN THIS FOCUS MUCH OF HER
SERVICE ON COMPUTER SCIENCE.
IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN MEMBER
WOMAN MEMBER WILLIAMS BECAME THE
BOARDS FIRST AND ONLY COMPUTER
SCIENCE EDUCATION LEAD.
AND HAS BEEN A LIAISON THE PAST
FOUR YEARS THE NATIONAL AND
STATE COMPUTER SCIENCE EDUCATION
ADVOCATES SUCH AS CODE DOT ORG
AND THE NEW CS FOR CA COALITION.
SHE IS ALSO LED THE BOARD'S
GUIDANCE TO AND SUPPORT OF THE
COMPUTER SCIENCE STANDARDS
ADVISORY COMMITTEE.
AND THE COMPUTER SCIENCE
STRATEGIC IMPLEMENTATION
ADVISORY PANEL COORDINATED BY
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
WORK.
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING THESE CHAMPIONS OF
COMPUTER SCIENCE THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSEMBLY.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING BACK. TO
ITEM ONE FORTY ONE S. B. NINE
SIXTY THREE MISTER QUICKLY.
THREE SENATE BILL NINE SIXTY
THREE BY SENATOR ALLEN ACCOLADE
WATER.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER MERCER
TO YOUR RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER I AM PRESENTING SP NINE
SIX THREE THIS IS A DISTRICT
WELL.
REGARDING THE WATER
REPLENISHMENT DISTRICT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA TO ALLOW
GREATER RESERVES TO PAY FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE.
NECESSARY FOR SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA TO CUT DOWN ON IS
IMPORTED WATER AND TO BUILD THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR WATER
RECYCLING.
AND GROUNDWATER REPLENISHMENT
THIS THROUGHOUT THIS BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION AS RECEIVED STRONG
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN BOTH
HOUSES I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK MISTER COURT PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL-ON ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
MR CLICKING ME CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTES EYES FIFTY NINE
NO ZERO THE ITEM [inaudible]
PASSES.
MOVING AHEAD IN FIREWORKS ITEM
ONE FORTY FIVE SP TWELVE WHO TO
MISTER CLERK PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL TWELVE OR TWO BY SENATOR
STONE ACCOLADE IN LAND USE.
SOME MEMBER MAYES YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MEDICARE AND
MITIGATION FEES ARE OFTEN
REQUIRED BY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ONE APPROVING A NEW DEVELOPMENT
PROJECT.
UNDER THE MITIGATION FEE ACT A
NEXUS STUDY MUST BE DONE TO
ENSURE THERE'S A DIRECT
CONNECTION BETWEEN THE FEES
COLLECTED IN THE NEED FOR NEW
INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND SERVICE FACILITIES TO OFFSET
THE STRING OF A GROWING
COMMUNITY.
UNFORTUNATELY MANY LOCAL
AGENCIES THAT COLLECT THESE FEES
FAILED TO MEET THE AND REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS OF THE MITIGATION
FEE ACT.
THE ACT IS CURRENTLY WITHOUT
CORRECTIVE MEASURES FOR FAILURE
TO COMPLY WHICH CAN FORCE LOCAL
DEVELOPMENT TO A COMPLETE HALT.
S. B. TWELVE A TO WOULD TRIGGER
AN INDEPENDENT AUDIT AND THE
LOCAL AGENCY WOULD HAVE TO PAY
FOR THE COST OF THE AUDIT.
IF THEY FAIL TO COMPLY WITH THE
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS FOR THREE
STRAIGHT YEARS THIS BILL IS A
NECESSARY TOOL FOR TRANSPARENCY
OF OF THOSE THE LEGISLATIVE
INTENT BEHIND THE MITIGATION FEE
ACT.
THERE'S NO OPPOSITION ON FILE TO
RESPECT THE REQUEST TONIGHT
THOUGH.
THANK YOU SEEN THAT NO REQUEST
TO SPEAK MISTER QUICK PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
MR CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTES EYES SIXTY
EIGHT NO.
ZERO THE MOTION PASSES.
MEMBERS A QUICK ANNOUNCEMENT
THAT THE CONFERENCE COMMITTEE
HEARING ON SB NINE NO ONE HAS
BEEN CANCELED.
MOVING AHEAD OF TIME ITEM ONE
FIFTY ONE S. B. NINE TEN MISTER
COOK PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL NINE TEN BY SENATOR
HERNANDEZ AND OTHERS AND I
BELIEVE HEALTH INSURANCE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHAT
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THAT AND
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS S. B. NINE TEN MAKES IT
CLEAR THAT SHORT TERM LIMITED
DURATION HEALTH INSURANCE MAY
NOT BE SOLD IN CALIFORNIA.
THESE POLICIES INCLUDING SENSE
EXTENSIVE HEALTH QUESTIONNAIRES
USED BY THE CARRIER TO EITHER
REJECT COVERAGE OR ONCE
TREATMENT OCCURS TO DENY
COVERAGE UNDER PREEXISTING
CONDITION CAUSES.
S. PLANS HAD OP HAVE OUT OF
POCKET MAXIMUMS AS HIGH AS
THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS.
COVERAGE GAPS THAT RANGE FROM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND TWO MILLION DOLLARS IN
SIGNIFICANT BENEFIT GAPS.
THE THREE LARGEST CARRIES OF
THIS INSURANCE HARPER SHORT TERM
COVERAGE WITH MEDICAL LOSS
RATIOS A 52% AND LOWER WHICH
MEANS THAT.
THEY'RE NOT SPENDING THE
APPROPRIATE AMOUNT OF MY MONEY
ON CARE.
HERE ARE THE PROBLEMS THAT
CREATED BY ALLOWING THESE
PRODUCTS IN THE MARKET.
THE CENSUS GO WOMAN WAS HIT WITH
A HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLAR CHARGE AFTER A SHORT TERM
PLAN REFUSE COVERAGE FOR A HEART
PROCEDURE.
COUPLE PURCHASE ONE OF THESE
POLICIES IN TWO MONTHS LATER THE
HUSBAND HAD A HEART ATTACK.
THE POLICY REFUSE TO COVER THE
NINE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
MEDICAL BILLS.
THIS ARE JUST A COUPLE OF
EXAMPLES SHORT TERM INSURANCE
INCREASES THE COST TO BE CA
PLANS BY DRAWING YOUNGER
HEALTHIER PEOPLE OUT OF THE ACR
MARKETS.
ONLY TO REENTER WHEN THEY HAVE A
HEALTHCARE CRISIS THE PROMOTION
THESE PLANS IS THE SABOTAGE OF
THE ACA ONE CARE OF THESE
PRODUCTS OPERATE THE COMMISSION
RATES AS HIGH AS 22%.
AND BONUSES TO INSURANCE AGENTS
OR SELLING SHORT TERM PLANS.
OPPONENTS OF SHORT TERM LIMITED
DURATION HEALTH INSURANCE ARGUE
THAT THESE ARE NEEDED TO FOR
LIFE TRANSITIONS ARE WHEN
SOMEONE IS BETWEEN JOBS.
THE ACA HAS SPECIAL ENROLLMENT
PERIODS IF CERTAIN Y.
TRANSITIONS OCCUR OUTSIDE OF
OPEN ENROLLMENT PERIODS AND AN
ELIGIBLE PER PERSON CAN ENROLL
IN MEDICARE AT ANY TIME DURING
THE YEAR.
MEDI CAL HAS NO OPEN ENROLLMENT
PERIOD WE ASK YOUR AIBO.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
COLLEAGUES I WANNA RICE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE --
SHORT TERM LIMITED DURATION
PLANS.
HAVE PLAYED A ROLE IN THE
MARKETPLACE BUT THE FACT IS THAT
SHORT TERM CHARACTER.
MUSIC AND LEAVE.
THERE'S A LOT OF ISSUES --
WITH THEM.
THEY CREATE CONFUSION AS TO WHAT
EXACTLY IS COVERED.
THEY OFTEN FOR EXAMPLE DO NOT
COVER MATERNITY COSTS.
THEY'RE VERY PRACTICAL THINGS
THAT MATTER THE LIVES OF PEOPLE
THAT ARE NOT.
TYPICALLY COVERED IN SHORT TERM
PLANS OF THIS CHARACTER.
SO YOU GET CONFUSED AS TO WHAT.
WHAT THEY COVER?
A AND THIS GETS COMPOUNDED SOME
IS BECAUSE THE WAY IN WHICH YEAR
SOLD.
PEOPLE SOLD THESE PRODUCTS WAS
SORT OF SHORTHAND DESCRIPTIONS
WHAT'S THERE.
LEADING TO CONFUSION.
THEY DO NOT COVER PRE EXISTING
CONDITIONS.
IT THIS MEANS THAT PEOPLE WHO
RELY UPON THESE.
CAN BE EXPOSED TO SIGNIFICANT
FINANCIAL LOSSES.
WHEN A CONDITION ARISES THAT
THEY THOUGHT MIGHT HAVE BEEN
COVERED IS NOT COVERED HERE'S
FINANCIAL LOSSES IS PERSONAL
EXPOSURE?
THINGS LIKE MENTAL HEALTH
MATERNITY ALL THESE SORTS OF
THINGS ARE NOT TYPICALLY COVERED
SO.
IT IS NOT UNUSUAL.
THAT WE WOULD.
OPT TO BAN THEM ALL TOGETHER.
THIS IS ACTUALLY.
A NUMBER OF STATES HAVE BEEN
LOOKING AT THAT EVEN BEFORE THE
EVENTS OF LAST YEAR WITH THE ACA.
THE PRODUCTS THEMSELVES ARE
PROBLEMATIC --
SO I ACTUALLY THINK THIS IS A
VERY.
GOOD BILL A VERY IMPORTANT BILL.
I THINK IT PROVIDES CLARITY.
ABOUT WHAT IS AVAILABLE IN
COVERAGE IT MEETS PEOPLE IN
THEIR LIFE NEEDS.
I THINK IT'S VERY GOOD PROPOSAL --
Y. ARE SENATE COLLEAGUE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ARAMBULA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR
OF THIS BILL AS WELL IS OUR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FROM SANTA ROSA.
I STAND TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
SENATE BILL.
NINE TEN THE INSURANCE WE
PROVIDE CALIFORNIANS SHOULD NOT
BE SUB PAR. TWO FOR THOSE WHO
NEED IT THE MOST.
IF AND IS BEING SOLD AS HEALTH
COVERAGE IT SHOULD NOT BE SHORT
TERM AND LACKING ANY
COMPREHENSIVE BENEFITS AND
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS
[inaudible]
SUCH AS SOME OF THESE PLANS DO
NOT EVEN COVER THE BASICS OF
PRESCRIPTIONS DRUGS MATERNAL
CARE OR MENTAL HEALTH.
THEY ALSO LACK THE IMPORTANT ACA
PROTECTIONS.
THESE TYPES OF INSURANCE PROVIDE
A FACADE THAT THE INDIVIDUALS
HEALTHCARE NEEDS WILL BE COVERED.
BUT IN REALITY THE ONLY MISLEAD
CALIFORNIANS AND DESTABILIZE THE
ACA MARKET.
THIS DESTABILIZATION IN PART
CAUSED BY THE SHORT TERM
INSURERS IMPACTS THE HEALTH CARE
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS BY
INCREASING PREMIUMS. FOR A CA
HEALTH COVERAGE.
THEREFORE WE SHOULD SUPPORT
SENATE BILL NINE TEN IN ORDER TO
ENSURE WE PROVIDE QUALITY
HEALTHCARE TO ALL CALIFORNIANS I
URGE YOUR SUPPORT TODAY FOR THIS
IMPORTANT VOTE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER VOEPEL
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
[inaudible]
I SPENT THIRTY NINE YEARS IN THE
INSURANCE BUSINESS AND FOR MANY
YEARS SOLD.
SHORT TERM POLICIES THEY HAVE A
TRUE USE IN THE MARKETPLACE.
MANY SELF EMPLOYED.
NEED SHORT TERM INSURANCE.
THIRTY DAYS SIXTY DAYS NINETY
DAYS EXCEPT ERA.
IN BETWEEN DIFFERENT OTHER
[inaudible]
ALTERNATIVES [inaudible]
ALSO.
SHORT TERM POLICIES.
WHEN THEY'RE SOLD HAVE MANY MANY
DECLARATIONS OF WHAT THEY DO AND
DO NOT COVER?
MANY CONSUMERS DON'T NEED
MATERNITY THEY DON'T NEED MENTAL
HEALTH.
AND THEY DON'T WANT TO PAY FOR
IT [inaudible]
THAT.
IS WELL SERVED BY SHORT TERM
POLICIES THAT ARE DESIGNED AND
SOLD.
AS GAPS BETWEEN OTHER TYPES OF
COVERAGE SUCH AS THEY SEE A
GROUP PLANS EXCEPT.
FOR SO THAT'S MY OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU SEEN AT NO FOR THE
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WHAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
THINK ABOUT A SPEAKER PERMITTING
SHORT TERM LIMITED DURATION
PLANTS IN CALIFORNIA WOULD TAKE
ITS BACK TO THE DARK DAYS BEFORE
THE AC.
OR CHEAP JUNK INSURANCE POLICIES
ARE AVAILABLE ONLY TO YOUNG
HEALTHY PEOPLE AND THE REST ARE
LEFT WITHOUT COVERAGE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CLICK PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL THOSE VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MR CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES EYES FORTY
THREE NO.
EIGHTEEN THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING NOW TO ITEM OF ONE FIFTY
FOUR SB ELEVEN NINETY TWO MISTER
CLERK PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL ELEVEN NINETY TWO BY
SANTA MONICA BACK RELATED
CHILDREN'S HEALTH THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY YOUR
RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I HAVE
BEFORE US THAT BIPARTISAN BILL
WITH NO OPPOSITION RELATE.
TO KIDS MEALS AND HEALTHY
BEVERAGES ESSENTIALLY THIS
REQUIRE.
A RESTAURANT WHICH PRIMARILY
SERVES --
KNEELS MARKETED CHILDREN TO MAKE
THAT DEFAULT DRANK AT HEALTHY
DRINK Y. WATER OR MILK WE KNOW
THAT CALIFORNIA IS IN THE MIDST.
OF AN OBESITY AND DIABETES CROP.
SO I THINK MANY PARENTS
[inaudible]
AND LOVED ONES WHO GO BUY A
HAPPY MEAL ARE SHOCKED WHEN THEY
REALIZE THAT A TRADITIONAL HAPPY
MEAL DRINK.
HAS NINE TEASPOONS OF SUGAR.
AND WEAK SOMETIMES STILL GUILTY
PUTTING THREE TEASPOONS OF SUGAR
IN OUR COFFEE OR EVEN TO BUT I
NINE AT TEASPOONS. FOR FIVE TEN
THREE YEAR OLDS DRINK IS
PROBABLY ISN'T GOOD FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH SO WHEN SIMON.
AYE I THINK IS IS A BASED UPON
THE PREMISE THAT KIDS MEALS
STUDENT COME WITH A SIDE ORDER
OF DIABETES.
AND OBESITY OR CARDIOVASCULAR
DISEASE AN ASPIRIN I FELT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MELENDEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER --
COLLEAGUES I DON'T DISAGREE THAT
WE SHOULD PROBABLY LIMIT THE
CONSUMPTION OF SUGAR NOT JUST IN
OUR CHILDREN'S LIVES BUT IN OUR
ALLIES BUT I DON'T THINK IT'S IN --
APPROPRIATE FOR THE GOVERNMENT
TO BE STEPPING IN AND SORT OF
TAKING THE PARENTS ROLE IF YOU
HAVE CHILDREN THEN YOU AND YOU
GO OUT TO EAT WHETHER IT'S AT A
FAST FOOD RESTAURANT OR SIT DOWN
RESTAURANT THING YOU HAVE
NOTICED.
THAT MOST OF THESE RESTAURANTS
OFFER CHOICES IT'S NOT JUST A
SODA THAT THEY GET WITH THE
CHILD'S MAIL THERE MANY CHOICES
AND THEN INCLUDES FAST FOOD
RESTAURANTS IT'S NOT.
NO LONGER IT'S NOT LIKE WHEN WE
WERE.
SO IT WAS THE ONLY OPTION NOW
IT'S CHAU BUT MILK ORANGE JUICE
OR ITS WATER SO IT'S NOT AS
THOUGH THIS HAVING A SODA IS
BEING FORCED UPON CHILDREN WHEN
THEY'RE OUT TO EAT WITH THEIR
PARENTS.
IT ALSO DOESN'T RECOGNIZE THE
FACT THAT REALLY IF THERE IS AN
ABUNDANCE OF SUGAR IN A CHILD'S
DIET LIKELY THAT'S COMING FROM
HOME BECAUSE MOST KIDS DON'T GO
OUT TO EAT EVERY NIGHT WITH
THEIR PARENTS.
SO IF THEY'RE HAVING TOO MUCH
SUGAR.
IT'S COMING FROM HOME OR SCHOOL
IT'S NOT COMING FROM GOING OUT
TO EAT SO I'M NOT SURE REALLY
HOW MUCH GOOD THIS WOULD DO
ANYWAY BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY.
IT IS IMPOSING A FINE ON
RESTAURANT OWNERS BEFORE.
I GUESS FOR NOT TAKING THE PLACE --
OF PARENTS IN FORCING THEM TO
ASSUME THE PARENTS
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THEIR CHILD'S
HEALTHY FOR THAT REASON I WOULD
URGE A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER HARPER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
THIS IS YET ANOTHER NANNY STATE
BILL THAT'S BEING PROPOSED IN A
POTENTIALLY BEING ADOPTED BY
THIS BODY.
I MEAN HOW MANY DECISIONS THAT
SHOULD BE MADE BY INDIVIDUALS
CONSUMERS BUSINESSES ON THEIR
OWN ARE INSTEAD BE BEING MADE ON
AYE THIS BODY BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
MY COLLEAGUE POINTS OUT A LOT OF
GOOD A A LOT OF POINTS TO BE
ABLE TO OPEN UP OPPOSE THIS BILL.
VERY SERIOUSLY LIKE WHAT'S NEXT
ARE ARE WE GONNA HAVE THE
DEFAULT POSITION OF REQUIRING
STAKES TO BEWELL DONE IN LESS
SOMEBODY ASKS OTHERWISE.
ORGAN INSIST THAT.
YOU HAVE TO HELP KILL IN YOUR
SALAD UNLESS YOU SPECIFICALLY
ASK OTHERWISE.
OR WE CAN AT MANDATE THAT YOU
DON'T HAVE A STRAW IN LESS
PEOPLE AFTER ALL WAIT A SECOND
THAT'S ALREADY BEEN PROPOSED
[inaudible]
SO.
HONESTLY HOW MANY WAYS ARE WE
GONNA TRY TO THREATEN SMALL
BUSINESSES LIKE RESTAURANTS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
I KNOW THE WEATHER'S GREAT I
KNOW THE BEACHES BEAUTIFUL I
KNOW OUR MOUNTAINS ARE
OUTSTANDING.
BUT SERIOUSLY PEOPLE ARE
SNAPPING BECAUSE OF THE ANTI
BUSINESS ATTITUDES IN THIS STATE
I URGE AND NO VOTE.
SOON AND NO FURTHER REQUEST TO
SPEAK MR MCCARTY WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE.
MR CLARKE YOU MAY OPEN THE ROLE
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
VOTE
.
MR MCCARTY MOVES THE CAR.
MOVING TO ITEM OF ONE FIFTY NINE
S. B. SIX EIGHTY EIGHT MISTER
CLERK PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SIX EIGHTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR MORLOCK INOCULATE THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES THANK YOU
MISTER COOLEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
MORNING OUR SPEAKER MEMBERS ARE
RIGHTS TODAY 2% S. B. SIX EIGHTY
EIGHT RELATED MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT REVENUE AND
EXPENDITURE REPORTS.
EVERY COUNTY IN CALIFORNIA USES
PROP SIXTY THREE FUNDS IN YOUR
OWN UNIQUE WAY WE READ WE
RESPECT LOCAL.
INITIATIVES.
FURTHERING THE GOAL TO PROVIDE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES TO THOSE
IN NEED.
WHILE THE VAST MAJORITY OF
COUNTIES MAKES US FLEXIBLY VITAL.
PARDON ME THE DIVERSITY OF OUR
COUNTIES MAKES THIS --
FLEXIBILITY VERY VITAL IN THIS
PROGRAMS ADMINISTRATION.
BUT THERE IS A LACK OF
CONSISTENT PORTING STANDARDS
MAKING DATA COLLECTION ANALYSIS.
DIFFICULT TO UNDERSTAND WHAT IS
BEING DONE.
ACROSS THE FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES
PROGRESS MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES.
MORE THAN A BILLION AND A HALF
OF MENTAL HEALTH FUNDS HAVE BEEN
AVAILABLE IN RECENT YEARS.
AND UP THE FIBERS IN THE FUNDS
CAN BE USED FOR STATE MYSTERY
PURPOSES.
WHILE SOME FOCUSED EVALUATIONS
SOON IMAGE MHSAA PROGRAMS
IMPLEMENT GOOD INTENTIONS.
THERE IS A QUESTION ABOUT THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF SOME OF THESE
PROGRAMS WITHIN THE COUNTIES.
AND A COMPREHENSIVE EVALUATION
IS NEEDED.
THIS IS ACTUALLY BEEN IN RECENT
YEARS A PRIORITY THE LITTLE
HOOVER COMMISSION.
WHICH FOCUSES UPON SOUND
ADMINISTRATION STATE PROGRAMS.
OF THIS BILL INCREASES PRESS
PERCHING CONSISTENCY OF FINANCE
REPORTING FOR ME JUST SAY.
INSURERS THE ANNUAL REVENUE
EXPENSE REPORTS CAN BE BOTH
ANALYZED AND REFERENCE.
IMPROVING ARRIVED RELIABILITY IS
REPORTING STANDARDS.
WILL INCREASE ACCOUNTABILITY THE
FUNDS SIMPLIFY ACCOUNTING RIGHT
TO COMPETE BECAUSE OF YOU OF
MHSAA FUNDING.
THE BILL HAS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
DROPLETS A PROCESS AND I URGE
YOU TO RECEIVE YOUR AYE VOTE
TODAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SEEN THAT NO REQUEST
TO SPEAK MISTER QUICK PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
MR CLERK.
YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTES I SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO
THE MEASURE.
PASSES.
MOVING TO ITEM ONE SIXTY S. B.
THIRTEEN AT SIXTY THREE MISTER
QUICKLY STREET.
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN SIXTY THREE
BY SENATOR MORLOCK ANOTHER
CYNICAL IN THE TAXATION OF MAKE
AN APPROPRIATION OF FOUR THINK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS TO THEIR
RIGHT TO PRESENT SENATE BILL.
THIRTEEN SIXTY THREE SENATE BILL
THIRTEEN SIXTY THREE ESTABLISHES
A VOLUNTARY CHAT TAX CHECKOFF.
THE FUND THE TRAINING OF CRISIS
INTERVENTION TEAMS TO ASSIST
POLICE OFFICERS AND HOW TO DEAL
WITH INDIVIDUALS GOING THROUGH A
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS.
THIS BILL WILL GIVE LAW
ENFORCEMENT TOOLS TO PERFORM
THEIR JOB MORE EFFECTIVELY AND
SAFELY.
IT WILL ALSO HELP KEEP PEOPLE
LIVING WITH MENTAL ILLNESS OUT
OF JAIL AND GET THEM INTO
TREATMENT PROGRAMS.
PUBLIC SAFETY OFFICIALS WILL BE
TRAINED BY THE CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL.
THIS BILL SPONSORED BY THE
NATIONAL ALLIANCE OF MENTAL
ILLNESS CALIFORNIA AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION A RUSH FACTORY AFTER
I WROTE.
THANK YOU SEEING NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE MISTER QUICK PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL-ON ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
MISTER CLARK PLEASE CLOSE THE
RULING TIED THE VOTES I SIXTY
NINE NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER THERE IS A RULES
COMMITTEE RESOLUTION AT THE DESK
RELATIVE TO S. B. TWENTY TWO
WIENER AND AS BEFORE SIXTY DALY
ON I ASK THAT WE GO. TO THAT
ITEM NOW.
THERE'S A RESOLUTION AT THE DESK
JUST TO SUSPEND JOINT RULE SIXTY
ONE TO ALLOW A COMMUNICATIONS
AND CONVEYANCE COMMITTEE TO HEAR
S. B. EIGHT TWENTY TWO AM EST
BEFORE SIXTY AFTER.
THE JOINT RULE DEADLINES AND TO
ALLOW THE PRIVACY AND CONSUMER
PROTECTION COMMITTEE ON THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE TO HEAR
S. BEFORE SIXTY AFTER THE
DEADLINES.
THE CLERK WILL READ THE
RESOLUTION TO SUSPEND THE JOINT
RULES.
RESOLVE THEIR JOINT RULE SIXTY
ONE BE THIRTEEN FOURTEEN FIFTEEN
AND SIXTEEN BE SUSPENDED TO
PREVENT THE COMMITTEE WAS ALL
COMMUNICATION CONVEYANCE PRIVACY
AND CONSUMER PROTECTION AND
APPROPRIATIONS TO MEET
CONSIDERABLE PORTS SENATE BILLS
FOR SIXTY EIGHT TWENTY TWO FOR
FURTHER ACTION.
MEMBERS THE RESOLUTION TO
SUSPEND THE JOINT RULES IS NOT
DEBATABLE IT REQUIRES A TWO
THIRDS ROLL CALL VOTE.
THE CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL-ON.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
VOTE
.
MR CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
AND HOW THE VOTES EYES FIFTY SAW
FIVE KNOWS FOURTEEN THE RULES
ARE SUSPENDED.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AT THE
REQUEST OF THE OUT THERE PLEASE
WITHDRAWAL AB TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY NINE COME TOGETHER FROM
ENROLLMENT.
THE BILL OF THE SENATE.
SHALL BE THE ORDER.
AT THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW MOAN PLEASE
GIVE A ONE DAY NOTICE TO REMOVE
ITEM A TWENTY SEVEN S. BEFORE
SIX AYE JACKSON FROM THE NOT THE
FILE WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. ONE DAY
NOTICE.
MOVING BACK TO BUSINESS ON THE
DAILY FILE ITEM OF ONE SIXTY ONE
S. B..
TEN FIFTY FIVE THE CLERK PLEASE
READ.
SENATE BILL TEN FIFTY FIVE BY
SARAH RAFFARIN AB AN FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS.
THANK YOU SO MEMBERS AMMONIA
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER S. B.
TEN FIFTY FIVE WOULD AUTHORIZE
BANKS AND CREDIT UNIONS IN
CALIFORNIA TO OFFER.
PRICE LINKS SAVINGS ACCOUNTS
ADDING CALIFORNIANS THE LIST OF
TWENTY EIGHT OTHER STATES IN THE
COUNTRY THAT HAVE ALREADY
AUTHORIZED THESE PRODUCTS.
PRICING SAVINGS ACCOUNT AND
COURAGE PEOPLE TO SAVE BY
OFFERING DEPOSITORS CHANCES TO
WIN PRIZES.
STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THAT PRICE
LINKED ACCOUNTS ARE ATTRACTIVE
ACROSS ALL AGE RACE INCOME
LEVELS BUT TEND TO BE MOST
POPULAR AMONG POPULATIONS.
THAT TEND TO BE LESS INCLINED TO
SEE SUCH AS LOW INCOME
INDIVIDUALS AND THE UNBANKED. TO
DATE PRICE LINKED ACCOUNTS
AUTHORIZED IN OTHER STATES HAVE
HELPED OVER SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND AMERICANS SEEM OVER A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS.
S. B. TEN FIFTY FIVE IS
SUPPORTED BY SEVERAL NONPROFITS
FOCUS ON HELPING STRENGTH IN THE
FINANCIAL SECURITY OF VULNERABLE
AMERICANS INCLUDING
COMMONWEALTHS THE MISSION AS A
FAN.
AND EARNED.
THE BILL IS ALSO SUPPORTED BY
THE BANKING AND CREDIT UNION
TRADE ASSOCIATIONS IN CALIFORNIA
INCLUDING THE CALIFORNIA BANKERS
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
BANKING NETWORK AND THE
CALIFORNIA CREDIT UNION LEAGUE.
THE BILL HAS AND NO OPPOSITION
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEN NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK MISTER CORPORATE OPEN THE
ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE SIRED A VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
MR CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES.
I SEVENTY NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES.
MOVING TO ITEM ONE SIXTY THREE
SBTEN EIGHTEEN MISTER QUICKLY.
THREE SENATE BILL TEN EIGHTEEN
BY SENATOR ALLEN ACTUALLY TO
ELECTIONS THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES.
TODAY OUR STATE ASSEMBLY SENATE
BORDER LEGALIZATION AND
CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICTS ARE
DRAWN BY AN INDEPENDENT
REDISTRICTING COMMISSION.
S. B. TEN EIGHTEEN BUILDS UPON
PASSED LEGISLATION BY GIVING
SCHOOL DISTRICTS COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICTS AND SPECIAL
DISTRICTS THE A THORNY TO
ESTABLISH INDEPENDENT HYBRID OR
ADVISORY REDISTRICTING
COMMISSIONS.
THAT MAKES VARIOUS CHANGES TO
STREAMLINING CLARIFY THE LAW
ALLOWING LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO
CREATE REDISTRICTING COMMISSIONS.
THIS WILL BRING MORE TRANSPARENT
AND NONPARTISAN REDISTRICTING
THE LOCAL JURISDICTION
JURISDICTIONS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
IMPORTANTLY THIS BILL PROVIDES
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS WITH THE
CHOICE TO UTILIZE INDEPENDENT
REDISTRICTING COMMISSIONS BUT IT
DOES NOT MANDATE THAT THEY DO SO.
SP TEN EIGHTEEN HAS RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
BOTH HOUSES --
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MISTER QUICK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTED THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. TO CLICK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES.
EYES FIFTY FIVE NO.
ONE THE MEASURE PASSES
.
MOVING NOW TO ITEM ONE SIXTY
SEVEN SP TWELVE THIRTY TWO
MISTER QUICKLY ST.
SENATE BILL TWELVE THIRTY TWO BY
SENATOR RAFFARIN HAPPILY TO
VICTIMS OF CRIME IN MAKING A
PROBATIONER.
FOR THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED EGGMAN
OF SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES.
RICE WAS IN S. B. TWELVE THIRTY
TWO ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
BRADFORD THIS BILL SIMPLY
EXTENDS THE TIME PERIOD IN WHICH
A YOUNG PERSON.
WHO HAS BEEN THE VICTIM OF A
CRIME CAN SUBMIT AN APPLICATION
FOR COMPENSATION WITH THE
CALIFORNIA VICTIM COMPENSATION
BOARD?
SPILL HAS ZERO NO NO NO VOTES
AND ZERO OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING IN A REQUEST TO
SPEAK MISTER QUICK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
YOU CLICK YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES.
I SIXTY SIX KNOWS.
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING AHEAD TO ITEM ONE SEVENTY
ONE S. B..
THREE ELEVEN MR CLERK PLEASE
READ.
SENATE BILL THREE ELEVEN BY
SENATOR PAN ACRYLATE CANNABIS IN
THE CLEAR HERE'S EUROPE'S TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BENEFIT
REMEMBERS S. B. THREE ELEVEN BY
SENATOR PENN WAS IS THE RECENTLY
AMENDED TO CLARIFY EXISTING LAW
WITH RESPECT TO A CANNABIS
PRODUCTS TO GO FROM A LICENSED
DISTRIBUTOR TO IT --
LICENSED --
AREA WITH A STRICT
INTERPRETATION OF LAW RESPECT WE
ASK FOR A VOTE [inaudible]
THANK YOU SEEING NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE MISTER QUICK PLEASE
OPEN THE ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
THE CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES.
I SIXTY TWO NO.
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
ON EMERGENCY AND ON THE BILL BY
SIXTY TWO NO.
ZERO MOVING TO ITEM ONE SEVENTY
TWO S. B. TWELVE FORTY SIX
MISTER QUICKLY THREE SENATE BILL
TWELVE FORTY SIX MONTHS SOON
REGAINED TACKLING A TAXATION.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KILEY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER THIS IS
SENATE BILL TWELVE FORTY SIX BY
SENATOR GAINES IT WILL
STREAMLINE THE PROCESS RETURNING
PROPERTY TAX REFUNDS.
THE CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS UNDER
CURRENT LAW IF YOU'RE A TAXPAYER
WHO'S OWED MONEY DUE TO AN
OVERPAYMENT OF TAXES PENALTIES
OR ASSESSMENTS THE COUNTY HOUSE
TO MAIL YOU A REFUND CLAIM FORM
WHICH YOU MUST THEN --
SIGN AND RETURN BEFORE A REFUND
CAN BE ISSUED.
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW THE COUNTY
TO PAY THE TAX PAYER WHAT IS
OWED WITHOUT ALL THIS
UNNECESSARY PAPERWORK THE BILL
HASNO OPPOSITION IT'S RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
AND I ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING THEIR REQUEST
TO SPEAK MISTER QUICK PLEASE
OPEN THE RIGHT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MR CLERK YOU MAY.
CLOSE THE ROLE AND HOW THE VOTES
AYE SIXTY SEVEN KNOWS ZERO THE
MOTION PASSES
.
MEMBERS ARE PREPARED TO LIFT THE
CALL IN ITEM ONE FIFTY FOUR S.
B. ELEVEN NINETY TWO MISTER
QUICK PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WISHING TO VOTE.
MR CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES.
EYES FORTY FIVE KNOWS TWENTY
THREE THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS I AM GOING TO MOVE.
TEMPORARILY TO ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY FOR A VERY SPECIAL A
GERMAN IN MEMORY.
AND THEN MOVE BACK TO FILE ORDER.
MISTER FRAZIER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN IN
MEMORY.
IF YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
IT IS WITH GREAT SADNESS THAT I
RISE TODAY TO ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF THAT FIRM CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL OFFICER.
KIRK RISKS.
IN A TRAGEDY.
WE ALL ARE STILL TRYING TO COME
TOGETHER.
AND GET GRIPS WITH.
OFFICE ADDRESS WAS KILLED DURING
THE PERFORMANCE OF HIS DUTIES.
I JUST LAST WEEK.
HE WAS A WELL LOVED AND
RESPECTED VETERAN MOTORCYCLE
OFFICER WITH MORE THAN NINETEEN
YEARS OF EXPERIENCE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL.
HE SERVED HIS COUNTRY IS A
UNITED STATES MARINE AND WAS A
DEVOTED HUSBAND [inaudible]
AND FATHER.
RESIDENT OF BACK A BILL.
HE SPENT SIXTEEN YEARS OF HIS
CHP CAREER SERVING SOLANO COUNTY.
WHERE HE WAS ASSIGNED IN? TWO
THOUSAND TWO PRIOR TO THAT HE
WORKED IN THE C. H. P.'S CONTRA
COSTA AN OPEN AREA OFFICES.
OUR PRAYERS AND CONDOLENCES ARE
OFFERED TO HIS WIFE CARRYING.
IS TWO ADULT DAUGHTERS HE AND
CASEY.
AND HIS SON COAL.
IN THE GALLERY US TODAY.
ARE A NUMBER OF OFFICERS.
OFFICER GRISES COLLEAGUES.
WHO SERVED WITH HIM IN THE
GOLDEN GATE DIVISION I THANK
THEM FOR BEING HERE TODAY?
IS FELLOW OFFICERS HIS FAMILY
AND FRIENDS KNEW HIM AS A MAN.
WHO DEEPLY LOVED PEOPLE?
HE WAS CHARISMATIC AND THE TYPE
OF PERSON WHO'S READY TO HELP
ANYONE AT ANYTIME.
SATURDAY MORNING HIS COLLEAGUES
LED A LONG PROCESSION.
A FIRST RESPONDER VEHICLES THAT
ESCORTED OFFICER CHRIS FROM THE
CORONER'S OFFICE IN FAIRFIELD TO
BACK IT HILLS CHAPEL.
IN BACK OF HILL.
ON MONDAY MORNING I ATTENDED
THEM WITH THEM.
A BILL TOLL TRIBUTE CEREMONY IN
MEMORY OF OFFICER CHRIS AT THE
CHP ACADEMY.
IN WEST SACRAMENTO.
THE HEARTBREAKING LOSS OF
OFFICER GRIST LOW PERFORMING HIS
JOB. TO MAKE OUR HIGHWAYS SAFER.
SERVES AS A REMINDER OF THE
GRAVE RISK LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS TAKE EVERY DAY
[inaudible]
ATTACKED SERVE ALL OF US.
JUST DAYS BEFORE THE TRAGIC
ACCIDENT THAT TOOK HIS LIFE
OFFICER CHRIS WAS DISCUSSING
WAYS TO MAKE OUR HIGHWAYS.
SAFER WITH HIS DIVISION CHIEF.
HE WAS A DEVOTED VETERAN OFFICER
WHO SERVED AS AN OUTSTANDING
ROLE MODEL FOR YOUNGER OFFICERS.
HE WILL BE SORELY MISSED.
PLEASE MEMBERS YES AND VISITORS.
JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF SILENCE
AS WE OBSERVE THE END OF WATCH.
FOR OFFICER CHRIS
.
THANK YOU MEMBERS
[inaudible]
WHILE.
MOVING TO ITEM ONE SEVENTY FOUR
S. B. NINE SIXTY NINE MISTER
QUICKLY.
THREE SENATE BILL NINE SIXTY
NINE BY SENATOR DODD OTHERS IN
ACCOLADES AUTOMATIC GARAGE DOOR
OPENERS THANK YOU SOME MEMBER OF
YOUR CAREER RECOGNIZED.
YOU MADAM SPEAKER IN MEMBERS.
SP NINE SIX NINE REQUIRES
RESIDENTIAL GARAGE DOOR OPENERS
MANUFACTURED IN CALIFORNIA ON OR
AFTER JULY. ONE TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN TO HAVE A BACKUP
BATTERY THAT IS DESIGNED TO
OPERATE DURING AN ELECTRICAL
OUTAGE.
SADLY DURING THE OCTOBER TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN NORTH BAY
FIRES.
THERE ARE NUMEROUS REPORTS OF
PEOPLE WHO DIED IN THEIR GARAGES.
GROWTH THROUGH GARAGE DOORS OR
HAD TO RELY ON EMERGENCY
PERSONNEL AND NEIGHBORS TO
EVACUATE. FOR ANY INDIVIDUAL
UNABLE TO MANUALLY LIFT A GARAGE
DOOR.
A BACKUP BATTERY PROVIDES AN
ADDED DEGREE OF SAFETY TO HELP
RESIDENTS QUICKLY ESCAPE FROM
THE DISASTER.
WERE ELECTRIC POWER IS LOST.
THIS BILL HAS ENJOYED IN
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
EYES RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEE IN A REQUEST TO
SPEAK MISTER CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE THE
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. TO CLICK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLAND TALLY THE VOTES EYES
FIFTY THREE NO SIX THE MEASURE
PASSES
.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING BACK AND
FILE ORDER TO ITEM ONE TWENTY
NINE ACR TWO FIFTY EIGHT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA MET
MISTER CLERK PLEASE READ SO WE
CAN CURRENT RESOLUTION TWO FIFTY
EIGHT BY SOME WE WERE GLORIA
OTHERS RELATIVE TO PRE EXPOSURE
PROPHYLAXIS IN POST EXPOSURE
PROPHYLAXIS.
AWARENESS DAY.
THANK YOU AS A MEMBER GLORIA
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER.
COLLEAGUES I RISE TODAY IN ASK
YOUR ATTENTION. FOR ACR TWO
FIFTY EIGHT TO ESTABLISH CRAP
AND PEP AWARENESS DAY IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
MEMBERS HERE IN THE GOLDEN STATE
THERE ARE APPROXIMATELY A
HUNDRED AND FORTY THOUSAND OF
OUR RESIDENTS WHO ARE LIVING
WITH HIV.
NOW ANNUALLY CALIFORNIA SEIZE
THE LARGEST NUMBER OF NEW HIV
DIAGNOSES IN THE COUNTRY.
ESPECIALLY IN LOS ANGELES SAN
FRANCISCO AND IN MY HOME COUNTY
OF SAN DIEGO.
ANTI RETROVIRAL.
MEDICATIONS SUCH AS PRE EXPOSURE
PROPHYLAXIS AND POST EXPOSURE
PROPHYLAXIS PRATT AND PAT.
I HAVE BEEN SHOWN TO BE SAFE AND
EFFECTIVE IN REDUCING THE RISK
OF ACQUIRING HIV.
BY SIMPLY TAKING PREP ONCE A DAY.
PEOPLE WHO ARE AT HIGH RISK FOR
EXPOSURE CAN REDUCE THEIR RISK
OF CONTRACTING THE VIRUS.
BY MORE THAN 90%.
BUT ONLY ABOUT 12% OF THOSE ONE
POINT TWO MILLION AMERICANS WHO
LIVE AT HIGH RISK FOR HIV
EXPOSURE HAVE ACTUALLY
PARTICIPATED ARE INITIATED THE
PREP REGIME.
ADDITIONALLY FOR CALIFORNIA
WHO'VE BEEN EXPOSED TO HIV PAT.
JUST WOULD TAKE IF IT TAKEN
WITHIN SEVENTY TWO HOURS HAS
BEEN SHOWN TO BE EFFECTIVE IN
REDUCING THE RISK OF ACQUIRING
HIV.
MEMBERS RACIAL AND ETHNIC
DISPARITIES IN HIV PREVALENCE
PROCESSED FROM THE LACK OF
AWARENESS FOR THESE MEDICATIONS
AND FOR THE STIGMA SURROUNDING
THE DIAGNOSIS.
ESPECIALLY AMONG PEAPOD
RELATIONS RIGHT THE GREATEST
RISK OF HIV INFECTION.
AND ALTHOUGH WE OUGHT TO BE SO
PROUD OF WHAT HAS BEEN DONE TO
REDUCE.
THE MORBIDITY OF HIV.
PERFECTLY THAT WE'VE MADE HERE
IN CALIFORNIA WE KNOW THAT THERE
SO STILL SO MUCH MORE THAT MUST
BE DONE.
PLEASE JOIN ME TODAY AS WE
ESTABLISHED CRAP AND PEP
AWARENESS DAY IN CALIFORNIA TO
RAISE AWARENESS OF THESE LIFE
SAVING MEDICATIONS TO MITIGATE
THE SPREAD OF HIV.
AND TO BE A STATE THAT OUGHT TO
HAVE THE GOAL OF ANY NEW
INFECTIONS AYE IN CALIFORNIA AYE
ACID THE WILL BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WALDRON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I URGE
SUPPORT FOR ACR --
TO FIVE EIGHT AS WE RECOGNIZE
THE IMPORTANCE OF PREP AND PAP
IN.
TRYING TO GET ZERO WITH HIV
INFECTIONS IT REDUCES THE
COMMUNITY VIRAL LOAD
SUBSTANTIALLY WHEN IT'S IT HERE
TOO AND WHEN PEOPLE KNOW ABOUT
IT. ONE OF THE PROBLEMS IS WE
NEED TO RAISE AWARENESS BECAUSE
THIS ALMOST PROBABLY MORE THAN
ONE THIRD OF PRIMARY CARE
PROVIDERS WHICH IS WHERE MOST OF
OUR FOLKS GO FOR THEIR INITIAL
CARE.
ARE NOT PROFICIENT IN EVEN
[inaudible]
ARRIVING PAT.
THERE'S A STIGMA STILL ATTACHED
TO THAT DISCUSSION THERE'S
COUNSELLING ASSOCIATED WITH IT
AND AWARENESS OF IT NEEDS TO BE
RAISED IN ORDER TO ACHIEVE OUR
GOALS AYE ORIGIN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS I
RISE AS THE CHAIR OF THE
INFECTIOUS DISEASES IN HIGH RISK
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IN
SUPPORT --
ACR ONTO BIG DATA THINK THE
GERMAN UP FROM SAN DIEGO FOR
BRINGING THIS GOOD RESOLUTION
BEFORE US.
OF AFRICAN AMERICANS A LATINO
COMMUNITIES FACE THE WORSE
HEALTH OUTCOMES BECAUSE OF THE
LACK OF ACCESS TO PREP AND PAP.
THIS IS NOT MY FIRST TIME
SPEAKING ON THE FLOOR ON THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE SO I WOULD LIKE
TO ASK ALL OF US PLEASE SUPPORT --
ACR.
TWO FIFTY EIGHT THANK YOU SEEING
NO FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
MISTER CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLE THIS ROLE IS FOR CO AUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS RULES FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION.
MEMBERS THIS ROLE IS FOR CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
MR CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
THERE ARE SIXTY TWO COAUTHORS ON
THE RESOLUTION WITHOUT OBJECTION
WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THIS
ITEM ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SIGNIFY
BY SAYING AYE.
ALL OPPOSED THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED.
MEMBERS A BRIEF ANNOUNCEMENT THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WILL BE
MEETING AT ELEVEN THIRTY OR UPON
CALL OF THE CHAIR.
WE'RE MOVING NOW TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
DOES ANY MEMBER WHICH REMOVING
ITEMS FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE THE
CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND A
CONSENT CALENDAR ASSUMING JOINT
RESOLUTION THIRTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOI RELATIVE TO
CITIZENSHIP.
MISTER QUIRK PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLE ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
MR CLICK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES EYES
SEVENTY ONE KNOWS YOU'RE THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
WE WILL DEFERRED THE REMAINDER
OF THE CONSENT CALENDAR READING
UNTIL ADJOURNMENT.
THE SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS AUGUST SEVENTEENTH NO
FLOOR SESSION A CHECK IN SESSION.
MONDAY AUGUST TWENTIETH FLOOR
SESSION AT ONE PM.
THAT THE ASSN ABSENCE OF
OBJECTION THE QUORUM CALL IS
LIFTED WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS REGRET THE
PRIOR PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON OF
THE JOURNEY MEMORY MEMBERS
PLEASE.
TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR
.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
ARE REMOTE TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR FIRST A
GERMAN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
I I RISE TODAY TO INJURE AND IN
THE MEMORY OF MICHAEL J. WALL.
MIKE WONG WAS A PERSONAL FRIEND
AND A MENTOR. FOR ME FOR MANY
MANY YEARS [inaudible]
SOMEONE WHO --
I BELIEVE I FIRST MET DRIVE
FAIRLY SOON AFTER I GRADUATE
FROM COLLEGE HE WAS --
ACTIVIST.
IN THE BAY AREA AT THAT POINT
WORKING ON HATE CRIMES ISSUES --
REALLY DOING LANDMARK WORK IN
THAT AREA DEVELOPING A HATE
CRIMES REPORT FROM THE COUNTY.
REALLY PART OF OUR A VERY STRONG
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION CALLING.
ATTENTION TO THE ISSUE OF HATE
CRIMES AND I THE TIME WHERE WE
ARE UNFORTUNATELY SEEING MORE
AND MORE.
HATE VIOLENCE HIS WORK THIRTY
SOME YEARS AGO [inaudible]
GROUNDBREAKING --
IT IS WITH IRONY.
THAT I AT THAT POINT DIDN'T EVEN
KNOW ABOUT THE ELEVEN YEARS OF
WORK YOU DID PRIOR TO THAT.
AS MANAGING ATTORNEY FOR THE
ASIAN LAW CAUCUS A GROUP THAT I
WOULD EVENTUALLY GO TO BECOME
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR.
FOR IT AND WHOSEWORK ON THE
CORE NOBIS CASE WORK WITH FRANK
KOREMATSU WHO --
IS SOMEONE THAT EVERY LAW
STUDENT --
IN AMERICA KNOWS ABOUT FRED
KOREMATSU IN THE WORK OF THAT
ORGANIZATION BUT THE WORK THAT
MIKE WAS.
VERY MUCH THE CENTRAL --
TO WAS SOMETHING THAT HE WAS
HOME OUT OF A HIS AFFILIATION
WITH THE ORGANISATION LASTED --
UP TO THE TOP TO THE DAY HE
PASSED AND HIS --
SHOWING UP TO ALL THE DIFFERENT
FUNDRAISING EVENTS ALWAYS BEING
IN SUPPORT OF FIGHTING FOR OUR
CIVIL RIGHTS FIGHTING FOR OUR
QUALITY FIGHTING FOR JUSTICE.
ON BUT FOR ME I WILL NOT
REMEMBER HIM AS JUST SOMEONE
WHO'S JUST AND ACTIVISTS I
REMEMBER HIM.
AS SOMEONE WHO'S HAD SO MANY
INTEREST.
HE WAS AYE AND A MS AMAZING
TRIVIA.
OUR CONTEST PLAYER HE HE AND MY
WIFE WERE ON A TRIBUTE TEAM
TOGETHER.
IN HIS CAPACITY --
OF KNOWLEDGE HIS ABILITY TO
MEMORIZE SO MANY DIFFERENT
THINGS WAS EXTRAORDINAIRE.
HE WAS ALSO AN AMAZING COOK --
IF HE WAS ALSO SOMEONE WHO'S FUN
TO GOLF WITH.
IN SOMEONE WHO JUST HAD A ZEST
FOR LIFE IN FACT I PERSONALLY --
WAS NOT EVEN AWARE THAT HE WAS
ILL AND WAS EXTRAORDINARILY
SHOCKED TO HEAR ABOUT HIS
PASSING --
HE'S SOMEBODY WHO IS --
DEVELOPED TO HIS WIFE SUE ARE
HIS SONS --
DENNIS AND GARY --
DOLLARS LAWS AND AND SIERRA AND
THEY'RE THREE GRAND CHILDREN --
LENA NO I IN ZACHARY IN FACT
THAT THAT YOU KNOW SOME OF HIS.
ALMOST FUN ACTIVITIES WERE
HAVING DIM SUM WITH HIS SON
GRANDSON ZACH AND NOAH --
FOR ME HE IS A HUGE LOSS IN OUR
COMMUNITY --
HE HAD THE HONOR OF ALSO WORKING
WITH OUR EVENTUAL MAYOR ED LEE.
THE FACT TO HEAR OF THEIR HIS OF
MERRILEES PASSING EARLY THIS
YEAR IN.
MY BLOG PASSING --
JUST JUST A FEW WEEKS AGO --
LEAVES ME WITH A VERY HEAVY
HEART -- BUT
ALSO DEMONSTRATES TO ME HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS. TO CONTINUE THE
WAR TO FIGHT FOR EQUALITY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL.
INNOCENT THAT MIKE WANTED EVERY
SINGLE DAY OF HIS LIFE AND
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT
THE ASSEMBLY.
ADJOURNED AND HIS MEMORY TODAY.
THANK YOU MISTER KING.
WE DID RECEIVE YOUR SECOND A
GERMAN MEMORY.
I ALSO LIKE TO ADJOURN --
THE ASSEMBLY THE MEMORY OF SOFIA
MOM WHO IS THE MOTHER OF MY
PREDECESSOR FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER NOW BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION MEMBER.
PHEROMONE --
SOPHIA MAL WAS BORN IN SWATOW
CHINA.
SHE WAS THE DAUGHTER OF A
PRESBYTERIAN MINISTER WHO
ENCOUNTERED MISSIONARIES IN
CHINA AND COST ONLY.
LIVED IN MANY DIFFERENT PLACES.
SHE EARNED HER BACHELORS OF ARTS
IN FINE ARTS FROM CITY
UNIVERSITY OF NEW YORK.
AND GOT MARRIED SHORTLY
AFTERWARDS IN.
NINETEEN SIXTY THREE AND LIKE
MANY WOMEN AT THAT TIME SHE
BALLOTS TO YOUNG KIDS AND A FULL
TIME JOB.
STILL EARNED A MASTERS OF
SCIENCE IN FINE ARTS EDUCATION.
FROM THE CITY UNIVERSITY OF NEW
YORK IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO SHE WENT ON
TO PURSUE A TEACHING CAREER OF
NINETEEN YEARS.
IN SRI UBER HIGH SCHOOL IN PORT
WASHINGTON NEW YORK.
THE SAME TIME SHE WAS RAISING A
FAMILY.
AND ARE PROVIDING HEALTHCARE
BENEFITS FOR HER FAMILY.
NOW OVER THE PAST TEN YEARS SHE
WAS HOSPITALIZED FOR VARIETY OF
AILMENTS --
HER DAUGHTER DOCTOR SAMANTHA
MARK GAVE HER GREAT CARE AND
COMFORT TO HER ESPECIALLY OVER
THE PAST. FIVE YEARS.
BUT SHE WAS OUR CARRY NUMBER TO
THREE CHILDREN --
FIONA --
MICHAEL AND SAMANTHA AND WAS --
AN AMAZING PARTNER TO HER
HUSBAND DOCTOR WILLIAM ARE.
OF OVER SIXTY YEARS --
SHE WAS SOMEONE WHO --
HAD AN AMAZING PERSONALITY IF
YOU EVER MET HER IN SAN
FRANCISCO YOU CAN AYE DEATHLY
SEE WHERE ARE ON BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION MEMBER AYE GETS HER
ZEST FOR LIFE YOU'RE REALLY --
INTER PERSONALITIES FRANKLY FROM
HER MOTHER YOU COULD SEE THAT
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
AND WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I'M ALSO GOING TO
UP RISE ALONG WITH MY OF SAN
FRANCISCO WEBSITE COLLEAGUE --
AS WE HONOR SO FEMA WHO LIVED A
VERY FULL LIFE OF ART CREATIVITY
MUSIC AND FAMILY.
AS YOU'VE HEARD SHE WAS VERY
ACTIVE WITH HER CHURCH --
IN MUSIC IN THE ARTS AND IN
TEACHING --
AND WE ALL KNOW THAT A
TREMENDOUS TESTAMENT TO ONE'S
LIFE IS THE LEGACY THEY LEAVE
WITH THEIR FAMILY --
AND SHE HAD BEEN THE DEVOTED
WIFE OF SIXTY YEARS TO HER
HUSBAND DOCTOR WILLIAM ARE.
A VERY CARING MOTHER TO HER
THREE CHILDREN VERY LOVING
GRANDMOTHER TO HER
GRANDDAUGHTERS AND OF COURSE --
THE MOTHER OF OUR FRIEND --
FORMER COLLEAGUE --
BOARD OF EQUALIZATION MEMBER
FEMA.
SO MEMBER EGGMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR JOURNEY
MEMORY.
I THINK YOU MISTER SPEAKER BUT
TODAY I RISE TO ADJOURN THE
MEMORY OF A LOVED REVERED MEMBER
OF THE STOCK AND COMMUNITY FACE
PHANTOMS --
SOME OF YOU MAY KNOW SPANISH
FAMILY OF FOR THEIR SPORTS
INVOLVEMENT.
I BUT WE IN STOCKTON THE
SURROUNDED COMMUNITY KNEW MRS
SPANOS -- AS
A LONGTIME STUCK TUNING IN --
AND WHILE THEY WERE VERY ACTIVE
IN DEVELOPMENT.
HER WORK IN PHILANTHROPY I THINK
WILL FOREVER MARK ARE OUR
COMMUNITY --
WHILE HER HUSBAND LIKE TO GET TO
THE SPORTS TEAMS THAT YOU A P.
SHE LOVED MUSIC AND THE ARTS AND
WOULD HAVE BROUGHT TO PEOPLE --
ENCOURAGED HIS GIVING AND THEN
THEREBY THEY'RE GIVING --
CONSERVANCY OF MUSIC AND A
COMMUNITY EVENTS ALL OVER I WAS
AT THEIR HOME.
COUPLE MONTHS AGO WHERE.
SHE OPENED UP HER HOME ANNUALLY
AND THE SUPPORT OF R. OR ANIMAL
SHELTER.
AND RAISE MONEY. FOR A POOR PETS
TO WEAR NEEDS OF HOMES --
I WAS THERE WHEN WE BROKE GROUND
AT SPANOS ELEMENTARY SCHOOL --
IN A COMMUNITY THAT HAD BEEN --
THEY HAD PUT UP A FENCE UP
AROUND THE PARK THERE WAS SO
MUCH CRIME AND DESTRUCTION THAT
WAS GOING ON AND IT WAS AN AREA
THAT.
WE FOCUSED ON DURING MY TIME ON
THE CITY COUNCIL WE'RE ABLE TO
GET.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THEIR THE
PARK CLEANED UP AND THEN THE
SPANOS ELEMENTARY SCHOOL OPENED
UP AND SHE CAME IN.
AND CONTRIBUTE TO THOSE CHILDREN
OUT WITH COMMITTEE MR SPELLS HAD
LIVED IN WHEN HE GREW UP.
THEY WERE MARRIED ON ALMOST
SEVENTY YEARS --
HAVE FOUR CHILDREN [inaudible]
DHEA.
JEAN MICHAEL AND ALEXIS --
THEY WERE PEOPLE WHO HAD THE
MEANS TO LIVE ANYWHERE IN THE
WORLD THAT THEY WANTED TO LIVE
AND THEY CHOSE TO REMAIN
STOCKTON AND BEING LONGTIME --
GIVERS ANNA AND JUST MISSES
MENACE WAS THE BEDROCK OF THAT
FAMILY AND YOU WOULD MEET HER
AND SHE WOULD JUST THAT YOU'VE
JUST EXUDE.
ON GRACE AND KINDNESS --
AND THE STALKING COMMUNITY IS
BETTER FOR HER HAVING LIVED AND
NANA WE ASK THIS CHAMBER TO REZA.
ADJOURNED IN HER MEMORY TODAY.
MISTER GIBSON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR JOURNEY MEMORY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS
SPEAKING MEMBERS AYE RISE TO AS
A BODY TO ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY.
OF MARIANNE O'NEILL WHO PASSED
AWAY ON JULY FOURTEENTH --
MARY ANTONIO WAS BORN ON
FEBRUARY FIFTH --
NINETEEN TWENTY SIX AT NINETY
TWO YEARS OLD --
SHE ACTUALLY CONTINUE TO DRIVE
UP UNTIL THE TIME --
WHERE SHE WAS HOSPITALIZED SHE
WAS BORN AND BRAXTON --
ARKANSAS WHERE SHE WAS RAISED
UNTIL AGE NINETEEN WHERE SHE
MOVED TO THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES.
SOON AFTER MEETING THE LOVE OF
HER LIFE A JOSEPH O'NEILL JUNIOR
IN NINETEEN FORTY SEVEN THEY GOT
MARRIED AND HAD TWO CHILDREN.
OF BOTH HUSBAND AND WIFE DYNAMIC
DUO TEAM EDUCATION WAS
DISTINGUISHED --
AS EDUCATORS IN LOS ANGELES REAR
AND IT. FOR OVER THIRTY YEARS
AND ALSO SHE SERVED ON THE
COUNTY BOARD OF EDUCATION OF FOR
MANY YEARS AS A REPRESENTATIVE --
FROM NINETEEN NINETY FOUR TO
NINETEEN NINETY NINE SHE SERVED
AT THE COUNCIL WOMAN THE CITY OF
CARSON.
WHERE SHE HELPED ESTABLISH THE
JOBS THAT WOULD BE OF O'NEILL
AND MARIANNE O'NEILL STROKES
CENTER SHE SERVED HONORABLY?
ON THAT PRESIDING AS A PRESIDING
I'M QUEEN MOTHER OF THE FANNIE
LOU HAMER QUEEN MOTHER SOCIETY --
OUT OF CASTING REVERSE DOMINGUEZ
HILLS RECENTLY SHE WAS NAMED BY
THE SEA OF CARSON IS BEING THE
FIRST GRANDMOTHER OF THE CD OF
CARS AND SHE IS SURVIVED BY HER
TWO SONS BRIAN AND KEVIN O'NEILL --
HER FIVE GRANDCHILDREN AND AND
HER SISTER AND MANY RELATIVES
SHE WILL BE MISSED WE* BODY
TO ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY.
OF FORMER CITY COUNCILWOMAN
MARIANNE O'NEILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS TIME WE
RECOGNIZE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER THURMAN FOR HIS
ADJOURNMENT.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
ARISE REQUEST THAT WE ADJOURNED
IN MEMORY.
OF MILLICENT HINA --
WHO PASSED AWAY ON JULY
SEVENTEENTH?
SURROUNDED BY HER LOVED ONES IN
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA.
A MILLICENT IS THE MOTHER OF
SOMEONE FROM THE CAPITOL
COMMUNITY.
AT THE NASA CAN HE NOW WHO
WORKED FOR MANY YEARS AT THE
WESTERN CENTER ON POVERTY AND
LAW.
IT NOW ADVOCATES ON A NUMBER OF
HEALTH CARE MATTERS.
KP PUBLIC AFFAIRS --
MILLIE AS HER FAMILY AND FRIENDS
CALL HER.
WAS BORN ON DECEMBER FOURTH.
NINETEEN FORTY THREE GEORGE AND
MARGARET KLUTE AT MILLIE GRUPPEN
PAOLO ALTO AND RECEIVED BOTH HER
BACHELOR'S AND HER MASTER'S OF
FINE ARTS.
FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA BERKELEY.
SHE WAS AN ACCOMPLISHED PAINTER
AND SHOWED HER WORK IN THE BAY
AREA IN THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES.
MILLIE BEGAN HER CAREER AT UC
BERKELEY STARTING AS A SECRETARY
IN THE CHEMISTRY DEPARTMENT IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX AND
RETIRING AS A MANAGER IN
FINANCIAL AND BUSINESS SERVICES
IN.
TWO THOUSAND FOUR DEDICATING
NEARLY THIRTY YEARS OF HER LIFE.
PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION.
LEE WAS AN AVID HOME CHEF AND
TRAVELER.
TOWARD EUROPE AND CALIFORNIA'S
COASTLINE WITH HER HUSBAND
ROBERT.
MILLION ROBERT SPENT FORTY
WONDERFUL YEARS TOGETHER AND SHE
IS SURVIVED BY BY ROBERT HER
DAUGHTER VANESSA AND HER
STEPSON'S STEPHAN AND ALEXIS.
MILLIE WILL BE DEARLY MISSED AND
I THANK YOU ALL FOR JOINING IN
HER MEMORY TODAY.
MEMBERS PLEASE BRING THE NAMES
OF DESKS REPRINT OF THE JOURNAL.
ALL REQUEST TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY
WILL BE DEEMED.
READ AND PRINT IN THE JOURNAL.
ALL OF THE REMAINING ITEMS WILL
BE PASSED AND RETAIN.
ALL MOTION SHALL BE CONTINUED.
SENATOR NO FOR THE BUSINESS
ALREADY ENTERTAINED MOTION TO
ADJOURN --
MISTER TRAVIS ALLEN MOVES AND MR
RUDY SALAS [inaudible]
ALL [inaudible]
JOINT.
MISTER TRAVIS ALLEN MOVES IN
MISTER SALAS SECOND SET THIS
HOUSE STAND ADJOURNED UNTIL
MONDAY AUGUST TWENTY ONE PM
.
VOTE CHANGE FILE ITEM.
ONE SEVENTY ONE I DON'T KNOW.
VOTE CHANGE SALAS SENATE BILL
THREE ELEVEN ITEM NO.
FILE ITEM NUMBER --
ONE FIFTY FOUR SP ELEVEN NINETY
TWO FROM I DUNNO.
O'DONNELL SENATE BILL ELEVEN
NINETY TWO ITEM NO
.
CONSENT CALENDAR THE CLERK WILL
READ SENATE BILL ONE SEVENTY
FIVE WITH URGENCY.
I SEVENTY ONE NOSE DOWN ON YOUR
SEAT.
I SEVENTY ONE NOSE DOWN ON THE
BILL SENATE BILL.
ONE NINETY TWO I SEVENTY ONE
DOES NOT SENATE BILL.
TWO SIXTY NINE I SEVENTY ONE
DOES NOT SENATE BILL SIX TWENTY
NINE I SEVENTY ONE DOES NOT
SUITABLE SEVEN SIXTY TWO WITH IT
WITH URGENCY.
I SEVENTY ONE KNOWS NOT.
ON THE URGENCY I SEVENTY ONE
KNOWS ON THE BILL SUITABLE.
SEVEN NINETY FIVE I SEVENTY ONE
KNOWS THE SENATE BILL.
EIGHT EIGHTEEN I SEVENTY ONE
THOSE TO SENATE BILL.
EIGHT EIGHTY AYE SEVEN ONE DOES
NOT SENATE BILL.
NINE OH FOR I SEVENTY ONE KNOWS
NOT SUITABLE.
NINE OH NINE I SEVENTY ONE DOES
NOT SENATE BILL NINE TWELVE I
SEVEN ONE DOES NOT SENATE BILL.
NINE SIXTY SEVEN I SEVENTY ONE
DOES NOT SUITABLE NINE SEVENTY
TWO I SEVENTY ONE BILLS ARE.
SENATE BILL NINE SEVEN SEVEN I
SEVENTY ONE DOES NOT SUITABLE
TEN TWENTY TWO I SEVENTY ONE
DOES NOT SENATE BILL.
TEN TWENTY EIGHT I SEVENTY ONE
DOES NOT CYNICAL TEN THIRTY NINE
I SEVENTY ONE DOES NOT SENATE
BILL.
TEN FORTY I SEVENTY ONE DOES NOT
SENATE BILL TEN SEVEN SENATE
BILL.
TEN EIGHTY I. SEVENTY ONE DOES
NOT SENATE BILL ELEVEN THIRTY
THREE I SEVENTY ONE KNOWS SO
NUMBER ELEVEN THIRTY SIX I
SEVENTY ONE DOES NOT SENATE BILL.
ELEVEN THIRTY SEVEN I SEVENTY
ONE KNOWS SEVERAL LEVIN SIXTY
FIVE I SEVENTY ONE DOES NOT
SENATE BILL ELEVEN NINETY FIVE I
SEVENTY ONE DOES NOT SENATE BILL
TWELVE OR ONE I SEVENTY ONE DOES
NOT SENATE BILL.
TWELVE SEVENTEEN I SEVENTY ONE
DOES NOT SENATE BILL BERTINO FOR
I SEVENTY ONE DOES NOT SENATE
BILL THIRTEEN OH FIVE I SEVENTY
ONE DOES NOT SUITABLE.
THIRTEEN SIXTY ONE I SEVENTY ONE
DOES NOT SUITABLE THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE I SEVENTY ONE KNOWS
NOW SEVERAL FOURTEEN THIRTY FIVE
I SEVENTY ONE KNOWS THE SENATE
BILL.
FOURTEEN NINETY TWO I SEVENTY
ONE DOES NOT SUITABLE FOURTEEN
NINETY EIGHT I SEVENTY ONE DOES
NOT SENATE BILL FIFTY NO.
THREE I SEVENTY ONE DOES NOT
SENATE BILL FIFTY OR FIVE I
SEVENTY ONE DOES NOT SENATE BILL.
FIFTY NINE I SEVENTY ONE KNOWS
NO SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION.
ONE FIFTY FIVE I SEVENTY ONE
DOES NOT AND SENATE BILL.
FOURTEEN TEN I SEVENTY ONE DOES
NOT.
THAT COMPLETES THE CONSENT
CALENDAR